AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND LIKE YOU
TO WALK WELCOME YOU ALL TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY SO QUITE A LOT TO
COVER.
OUT ONE OF THOSE BILLS -- ITEM
EIGHT SB FIVE NINETY TWO IS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- SO WITH
THAT WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
QUORUM WILL BEGIN AS A COMMITTEE
OF THE WHOLE AND INVITE UP OUR
FIRST AUTHOR.
A SENATOR WIENER FOR SB
.
ONE FIFTY NINE I JUST TWO OF
REMIND EVERYONE OF OUR GENERAL
RULES ON WITNESSES IN FAVOR
WITNESSES AGAINST FOR PROVIDING
SIX MINUTES ON EACH SIDE SO.
THOSE WHO ARE IN EACH SIDE
SHOULD WORK IT OUT SO THEY CAN
STAY WITHIN THE LIMITS AND THEN.
WE'LL ASK ASK PEOPLE TO COME TO
THE MIKE WITH ME TO THIS JUST TO
GIVE THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION --
SO WE CAN TRY.
TO GET THROUGH ALL OF OUR
BUSINESS TODAY SO VERY GOOD
SENATOR WIENER WELCOME YOU'RE
WELCOME TO TO BEGIN.
I THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN -- FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING TODAY ON SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY NINE AT A BILL
THAT WILL.
HELP US IN OUR EFFORT TO REDUCE
AND ULTIMATELY AND HIV
INFECTIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I WANNA START BY -- ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I
WANNA ACROSS MY PERSONAL THANKS
TO YOU -- AS CHAIR AND ALSO TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF UP WORKING
HARD AND DILIGENTLY WITH US OVER
THE LAST FEW WEEKS -- ON THESE
AMENDMENTS AND WE APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE BILL SO SERIOUSLY AND
HELPING US -- MOVING ON A
POSITIVE HOUSE OF THANK YOU --
COLLEAGUES ARE SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY NINE WILL EXPAND ACCESS --
TO TO CRITICAL -- AND POWERFUL
AND LIFESAVING -- HIV PREVENTIVE
MEDICINE MEDICATIONS.
SPECIFICALLY BY PRE EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS OR PROP.
AND POST EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS OR
PAP.
BY ALLOWING PHARMACISTS TO
FURNISH THEM UP FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME WITHOUT A PHYSICIAN'S
PRESCRIPTION.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY NINE ALSO
A PROHIBITS INSURANCE COMPANIES.
FROM SUBJECTING PROP AND TAPPED --
TO USELESS AND IRRATIONAL PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS OR STEP THERAPY --
PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS THAT DO
NOTHING EXCEPT TO PUT UP
BARRIERS AND DENY ACCESS.
WELL WE HAVE SEEN INCREASED USE
OF PROP AND PAP.
OUR PROGRESS UNFORTUNATELY HAS
BEEN SLOW AND UNEVEN -- TOO FEW
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE.
ON PROP IN PARTICULAR ARE NOT.
AND WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES -- BLACK AND LATINO
MEN IN PARTICULAR -- HAVE MUCH
LOWER PREVALENCE OF PREP USE.
THAN -- WHITE MEN WHO HAVE SEX
WITH MEN.
WE ALSO HAVE CHALLENGES IN OUR
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY OF
INCREASING UP TAKE A PROP.
MAKING IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE AT
RISK OF HIV TO ACCESS THESE
MEDICATIONS AND REMOVING
BARRIERS TO THAT ACCESS.
WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA HOPE YOUR
PLACE.
PREP IS A ONCE A DAY COBB HILL
FOR HIV NEGATIVE PEOPLE THAT
ALMOST ENTIRELY ELIMINATES THE
RISK OF BECOMING INFECTED WITH
HIV.
PAP IS A ONE TIME TWENTY EIGHT
TO A COURSE FOR PEOPLE WHO MAY
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED. TO HIV.
I HAVE CAN STOP THE HIV FROM
TAKING HOLD IN A PERSON'S BODY.
AS LONG AS A PERSON STARTS THE
MEDICATION WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS AND HOPEFULLY LESS.
OF EXPOSURE.
ALLOWING PHARMACISTS TO FURNISH
THESE MEDICATIONS AND PUTTING AN
END TO PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS OR
BOTH CRITICAL TOOLS TO HELP
EXPAND ACCESS.
CURRENTLY BOTH PRATHAM TAP A
REQUIRE A PHYSICIAN'S
PRESCRIPTION -- WHICH CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY DELAY OR EVEN
PREVENT SOME PEOPLE FROM
ACCESSING THESE MEDICATIONS.
SOME PEOPLE ARE NOT COMFORTABLE
GOING TO SEE A PHYSICIAN.
OTHERS STRUGGLED TO ACCESS A
POSITION GIVEN THE PHYSICIAN
SHORTAGE I IN MANY PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA -- AS WELL AS
SOMETIMES HAVING TO WAIT A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME BEFORE GETTING AN
APPOINTMENT THAT DELAYCAN BE
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN REMAINING
HIV NEGATIVE.
OR BECOMING POSITIVE.
MOREOVER WALT MANY PHYSICIANS
GET IT WHEN IT COMES TO SEXUAL
HEALTH.
AND THERE ARE SOME POSITIONS
MANY PHYSICIANS WHO ARE
INCREDIBLE ABOUT SEXUAL HEALTH.
OTHERS DO NOT.
ARE WE CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
REPORTS ARE FROM PEOPLE WHO GO
TO THEIR POSITION -- ASKING FOR
PROP.
ONLY TO BE TOLD THAT THEY SHOULD
BE -- JUST QUOTE UNQUOTE MORE
RESPONSIBLE.
THEY SHOULD JUST USE CONDOMS A
AND THEY REALLY SHOULDN'T TAKE A
NEW MEDICATION WHEN IT THEY WERE
JUST MORE RESPONSIBLE THEY WANT
YOU TO PUT UP HELL AND THEIR
BODY.
PEOPLE UNFORTUNATELY ARE STILL
GETTING THIS RESPONSE FROM SOME
POSITIONS. THREE CLEAR I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT OPPOSITION I WHEN
I WENT TO MY OWN POSITION FIVE
TO PROP.
UP MY PHYSICIAN WHO IS NOT LGBT --
GOT IT IMMEDIATELY AND CLEARLY
DEEPLY UNDERSTOOD SEXUAL HEALTH.
I WAS LUCKY NOT EVERYONE IS SO
LUCKY AND FOR MANY PEOPLE TO
HAVE THAT KIND OF REACTION --
THEY'RE GONNA SHUT DOWN AND
THEY'RE JUST NOT GOING TO USE --
THIS PROPHYLAXIS.
ASKING PEOPLE TO PUT THEIR LIVES
ON HOLD WHILE THEY GO THROUGH
THE CURRENT LOG OF TRYING TO GET
ON TO PROP.
WITH RESPECT TO SING A POSITION
AND HAVING YOUR INSURANCE
COMPANY POTENTIALLY DELAY
APPROVAL.
ON IT'S JUST NOT THE BEST
APPROACH TO PREVENTING HIV.
BY ALLOWING PHARMACISTS TO
FURNISH AN INITIAL THIRTY DAY
SUPPLY OF PREP.
AND THE ENTIRE TWENTY EIGHT DAY
COURSE OF PAP -- AND THEN FOR
PROPERTY WIRING A PHYSICIAN'S
PRESCRIPTION TO GO BEYOND THE
THIRTY DAYS WILL PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE ACCENTS.
ACCESS FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED IT --
WALL ALTERNATELY CONNECTING
PEOPLE WITH ALL OF THE CARE THAT
THEY NEED.
THIS IS NOT WITHOUT PRECEDENT
LAST YEAR OUR COUNTERPARTS IN
NEW YORK STATE.
PASSED A LAW ALLOWING
PHARMACISTS TO FURNISH THE FIRST
SEVEN DAYS A PATH.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE SEVEN DAYS IS NOT ENOUGH
TO CONNECT WITH THE POSITION AND
GET THE BLOOD WORK ETCETERA AND
SO THERE IS A BILL NOW IN NEW
YORK STATE TO EXTEND THE TO
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS -- OF COURSE
LIKE ALL MEDICATIONS WE'RE
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT PATIENT
HEALTH AND MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF ALL RISKS
AND MONITOR THEIR HEALTH.
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE PUT WITH THE
HELP OF THE COMMITTEE LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE STEERED -- TOWARDS
OUR PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS --
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE ACCEPTED
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE.
DO YOU SING NEW HIV INFECTIONS
ARE WOMAN TUNING POSITIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES IS THE GOAL OF THIS
LEGISLATION I BELIEVE IT WILL BE
THE RESULT -- EXPANDING ACCESS
IS WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT AND
THAT'S WHY I'M PROUD TO BE PART
OF COALITION WORKING THE PASSES
BE.
ONE FIFTY NINE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE
CAROLINE CHU.
WHO IS A POSITION WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO HEALTH NETWORK FAMILY
HEALTH CENTER?
COURTNEY MULHEARN PEARSON --
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION AND CLINT HOPKINS A
FOR ABOUT ACTUALLY.
HAWKINS THE PHARMACIST STYLE
WHOSE LOCAL HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AT TWO CHEESE -- PHARMACY.
CENTER WINNER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION OF THE BILL BEFORE
WE GO TO YOUR WITNESS IS AT TWO
WE HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT SO I
WANT.
TO ON A FORMALLY CALL THE ROLL.
GLAZER HERE GLAZER HERE CHIANG
ARCHULETA DODD GALGIANI.
JOHNNY HILL.
HELLO.
SO HERE LEYVA.
LEYVA HERE PAN.
WILL PRESENT OKAY OKAY SO WE
HAVE A QUORUM.
MR MY ANSWER MY NOTES WERE NOT
ENTIRELY ACTOR ALSO -- TAMMY
MARTIN WITH THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE PLEASE WE GET.
HI CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME OKAY.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
VOICE MY SUPPORT OF SB ONE FIFTY
NINE MY NAME IS DOCTOR CAROLYN
CHIU AND I'M A PEP AND PREP
EXPERIENCED PHYSICIAN AND
EDUCATOR.
AT ONE OF SAN FRANCISCO SAFETY
NET COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS.
I AM ALSO THE CLINICAL ASSOCIATE
DE DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
CLINICIAN CONSULTATION CENTER
WHICH IS OFFERED CLINICAL
DECISION SUPPORT AND EDUCATION
ON HIV TO CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
I FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE OF
WITNESSING AND BENEFITING FROM
THE GENUINE VALUE THE PHARMACIST
BRING TO HIV PREVENTION AND CARE.
NO MATTER WHAT COMMUNITY YOU
LIVE IN.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE PHARMACIST
PLAY UNIQUE AND NECESSARY ROLE
IN IMPROVING ACCESS TO HIV
PREVENTION SERVICES AND
ADVANCING PATIENT CENTERED HIGH
QUALITY CARE.
IN MY EXPERIENCE PHARMACISTS ARE
WELL TRAINED AND QUITE
EXPERIENCED WITH ENSURING
APPROPRIATE SAFETY AND CLINICAL
MONITORING REGARDING MEDICATIONS
AND PROVIDING MEDICATION
ADHERENCE COUNSELING.
THUS PHARMACISTS ARE READY WELL
EQUIPPED WITH THE CORE SKILLS
NEEDED TO SAFELY FURNISH PREP
AND PAT.
SEVERAL OF MY OWN PATIENTS HAVE
EXPRESSED HOW MUCH THEY
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION AND
LEVEL OF DETAIL GUIDANCE THEY
RECEIVE FROM THEIR PHARMACISTS.
ADDITIONALLY AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ALONE THE PHARMACIST I WORK WITH
ASSISTED PROVIDERS INCLUDING
PHYSICIANS ON ALMOST FOURTEEN
HUNDRED CASES INVOLVING PEP AND
PROP.
ALLOWING FOR THE PHARMACIST TO
FURNISH PEPIN PREP HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HELP US ACCELERATE
OUR CURRENT EFFORTS TO TURN THE
TIDE ON NOT ONLY HIV BUT ALSO
OTHER SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO EMBRACE THE
INNOVATION AND PROMISE THAT THIS
BILL REPRESENTS.
UNDERSTAND HOW IT CAN HELP OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM ELEVATE
EFFICIENT COLLABORATIVE TEAM
BASED CARE.
ADDRESS IMPORTANT DISPARITIES
AND IMPORTANTLY HELP CALIFORNIA
FULLY REALIZE IT'S INTEGRATED
PLAN TO GET.
TO ZERO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME IS
COURTNEY MOLEHAN PEARSON I'M THE
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF POLICY AT THE
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION
AND WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
AND BECAUSE BONTA RASPY -- ONE
FIFTY NINE WHICH WILL HELP --
INCREASE ACCESS TO PREP AND PATH --
TO FOR ALL THAT NEED IT I'M
CURRENTLY PROP UP TAKE ACROSS
THE STATE IS LOW HOW MUCH LOWER
THAN WHAT WE NEED IT TO BE IF
WE'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE OUR GOALS
OF GETTING -- TO ZERO WHICH WAS
LAID OUT IN THE STATE OFFICE OF
AIDS AND LAYING THE FOUNDATION
FOR GETTING TO SEE HER -- PLAN
RELEASED IN -- TWENTY SIXTEEN IN
THAT PLAN WE HAD A GOAL OF
GETTING -- SIXTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AT HIGH RISK FOR
HIV ON CRAP BY DECEMBER --
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT CURRENTLY
ARE OUR DATA AS A TWENTY SIXTEEN
INDICATED THAT ONLY NINE
THOUSAND PEOPLE OR I'M ACCESSING
PROP SERVICES SO CLEARLY WE HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO -- AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED OTHER STATES
LIKE THAT -- WHAT NEW YORK AND
ALSO WASHINGTON SEATTLE THERE'S
A PHARMACY THERE THAT ARE
ALREADY DOING THIS -- THAT WE
CAN LEARN FROM THEIR EXPERIENCE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS --
ADOPT THIS FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND BEYOND IT'S CRITICAL THAT IN
ORDER TO GET TO WHERE WE NEED TO
GO WE CAN CREATIVELY I'M AND
WORK TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES AND ENSURE THAT PROP
AND PEPPER AVAILABLE TO ALL WHO
NEED IT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CAN BE MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA JUST
BRIEFLY STATING THAT AS CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL IT IS A
HIGH PRIORITY FOR US.
AS PART OF OUR ONGOING HIV
PREVENTION WORK AND IN
CONSIDERATION OF THE BARRIERS TO
HEALTHCARE ACCESS THE LGBT Q.
CONTINUED OF THE PARTICULAR
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO FACE THANK
YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT CAN COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
HI CLINT HOPKINS WHICH IS
PHARMACY SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THE FORTY
PLUS YEARS INTO THE HIV CRISIS
WE STILL HAVE A CRISIS WE STILL
HAVE.
YOU HIV INFECTIONS OCCURRING
EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
NAMELY HERE IN SACRAMENTO WE'RE
ONE OF THE HIGHEST COUNTIES IN
THE IN THE COUNTRY TO HAVE NEW
HIV INFECTIONS.
THE BILL LIKE THIS WILL HELP TO
REDUCE THAT IMPACT AND BURDEN ON
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST PAT WHALEN ELLISON WILL
SNAP YOU SEE HERE ON BEHALF OF
UNITED NURSES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA UNION HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS WE REPRESENT
THIRTY THOUSAND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS.
INCLUDING NURSES AS WELL AS
PHARMACISTS AND APOLOGIZE TO THE
COMMITTEE WE GOT OUR SUPPORT
LETTER IN A LITTLE LATE BUT WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MARIA LOPEZ PHARMACIST SAN
FRANCISCO OUR MISSION WELLNESS
WE ARE THAT -- PREP
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT FOR THE
STATE -- WITH THE SENSE THAT A
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH I WANT TO
READ ONE STATEMENT FROM A
PATIENT WE SO IT.
IS THAT WE JUST HAVE A NAME AND
AND START FILIATION OKAY IF OF
QUESTION COMES UP WELL HAPPY AT
BY TRACK.
HI MICHELLE REAVIS -- WITH
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT PUBLIC
HEALTH PIECE OF LEGISLATION WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE HIV AIDS
COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR AMENDMENTS
AND STAFF AND THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER.
ALEXIS DAILY FROM SACRAMENTO ON
GT COMMUNITY CENTER.
AND WITH HIS CASTRO.
I'M WE ARE STANDING VILIFIED
WITH -- THEATER WINNERS.
EFFORTS FOR UPRIGHT NAVIGATION
AND ACCESS TO PRIVATE RESOURCES
ESPECIALLY DEALING WITH OUR
MULTI LEVEL MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
OKAY -- ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HE CLEAR A COUPLE SPACES ON THE
TABLE HERE FOR THEM TO COME UP
.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- FIRST I JUST LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THE HARD WORK THAT
WENT INTO -- THIS THESE
AMENDMENTS AND WENT INTO KIND OF
THIS ANALYSIS ON THIS ON THIS
BILL AND UNFORTUNATELY IT THOSE
HE MADE WILL REMAIN OPPOSED ON
AS AN AS PROPOSED AMENDED OR AS
THE COMMITTEE MINUTES -- ARE
TAKEN WELL WE UNDERSTAND WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE AUTHOR'S GOAL
TO COMBAT THE SPREAD OF HIV
PROBLEM PEPPER STRONG
MEDICATIONS THAT DEMAND A HIGH
DEGREE OF SAFETY IN
CONSIDERATION THAT WE BELIEVE
CAN'T BE ACHIEVED AT THE RETAIL
PHARMACY -- LEVEL SPECIFICALLY
ON CRAFT THE MEDICATION
CURRENTLY PRESCRIBED BY
PHYSICIANS -- AS A COMPONENT OF
A COMPREHENSIVE TREATMENT TO
PREVENT A PLAN IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND THAT DETERMINING A
PROP REGIMEN FOR PATIENTS IS NOT
STRICTLY OBJECTIVE.
AND IS BASED ON ONGOING
CONSIDERATIONS -- AND DISCUSSION
BETWEEN THE PATIENT AND THEIR
AND THEIR PHYSICIANS.
CURRENTLY PHYSICIANS THAT HERE
TO THE CDC GUIDELINES -- AS
STATED IN THE ANALYSIS AND WHEN
THEY PRESCRIBE PREP.
THEY INCLUDE IT INCLUDES
ASSESSING THE PATIENT FOR ANY
SIGNS OR SYMPTOMS AND THE QUEUE
HIV INFECTION ENSURING THAT THE
PATIENT HAS RECENTLY GIVEN A
TESTED NEGATIVE FOR HIV.
AND CONFIRMING THAT THE PATIENT
HAS A NORMAL KIDNEY AND LIVER
FUNCTION PHYSICIANS OFTEN WILL
TAILOR THESE MEDICATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THE PATIENT'S
REGIMENT IS MOST EFFECTIVE.
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION THE
PATIENT'S RISK AND OTHER FACTORS
THAT MAY PRESENT CHALLENGES AND
IN PETE AT HERE ADDS TO THE
MEDICATION.
HAVING PROP AND TO A PATIENT IS
MORE COMPLEX THAN JUST FOLLOWING
A STANDARD SET OF CDC GUIDELINES.
IT'S UNCLEAR AFFIRMS AS THE
RETAIL LOCATIONS LIKE FOR CVS
AND TARGET WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE PAID THE RENT THE
PRIVATE SPACE NECESSARY FOR
PATIENTS TO HAVE IMPORTANT
PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS WITH OF
WITH THE PHARMACIST ABOUT THE
HIV STATUS AND THE RISK FOR
INFECTION.
SEE MAY FEELS COMFORTABLE MOVING
THE BILL FORWARD IF IT DID NOT
AND CAN INCLUDE THE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO PROP -- FEELS
COMFORTABLE THAN WORKING TOWARD
A BETTER ACCESS ISSUE TO
UNDERSTAND THE ACCESS OF THE PEP
MEDICATION WE UNDERSTAND THE
URGENCY BEHIND TAKING PET
MEDICATION AS FAR AS NEEDING TO
TAKE IT WITHIN THREE DAYS AND
HOW THE PHARMACY CAN HELP.
ADDRESS THAT BARRIER -- BUT ON
THE ON THE PROPER MEDICATION AND
WE FEEL STRONGLY THAT IT SHOULD
BE REMOVED FROM THE BILL -- WE
DO APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO THIS BILL AND I
WOULD URGE RIGHT WORD ORDER NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS TREES A STARK WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE HEY WE DID
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AS WELL AND
WE REALLY WANT I THINK YOU AND
AND YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE WITH THE
SENATOR'S OFFICE IT'S AN
IMPROVEMENT.
THE BILL IS IS -- DEFINITELY
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
BUT WE DO STILL HAVE SOME SOME
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS -- ABOUT
WHAT REMAINS IN THE BILL AND I
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
KAISER PERMANENTE A STRONGLY
SUPPORTS.
REMOVING BARRIERS AND EXPANDING
ACCESS TO PEP AND PERHAPS WE
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
HIS WORK IN.
THE SUPPORTERS ON WHO ARE
WORKING ON THAT DEFINITELY -- A
SUPPORT THAT AND WE'VE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED THESE PROGRAMS IN
OUR OWN PHARMACY SO -- BUT WE
JUST THINK WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT HOW HOW WE DESIGN
THESE PROGRAMS AND I WOULD ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND WHERE WE
STILL HAVE SOME.
REMAINING CONCERNS I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT -- AN ISSUE AROUND
COVERAGE AND NO THAT'S NOT THE
THE PURVIEW OF THIS COMMITTEE
NECESSARILY BUT THE BILL ISN'T
VERY CLEAR.
ABOUT HOW -- THE MEDICINE AND
THE PROGRAM HERE WOULD ACTUALLY
BE COVERED -- I THINK THAT'S
EASY TO CLARIFY -- AND WE'D BE
HAPPY TO TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THAT IN OUR REMAINING
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS IN THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION -- FIRST OFF WE
ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE PEP AND
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL I'M LIKE THOSE VERY
MUCH -- WE ALSO RECOGNIZE AND
COMPLETELY AGREE THAT WE HAVE A
UTILIZATION PROBLEM -- WE DO NOT
BELIEVE HOWEVER THAT THIS BILL
IS A SOLUTION TO THAT
UTILIZATION PROBLEM.
ON BY TAKING AWAY WHAT THE FDA
THE CDC OUR OWN STATE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS BEEN SAYING
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WHEN
TRUE FATHER WAS FIRST APPROVED
FOR PREP -- IGNORE IGNORING THE
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
OBLIGATION OF THE POSITION TO BE
PART OF THAT DISCUSSION PRIOR TO
THE PRESCRIPTION -- THE CMA
REPRESENTATIVE AS INDICATED --
SOME EIGHT SOME GOOD ARGUMENTS
RELATIVE TO THIS ISSUE BUT I
WANT.
TO BRING IT INTO A VERY FINE
POINT RELATIVE TO THE HIV TEST.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE MAY NOT BE AWARE OF IS
THAT STILL EVEN AFTER ALL THESE
YEARS.
AN HIV TEST TAKEN SOON AFTER
SOMEBODY HAS BEEN EXPOSED TO HIV
CAN STILL COME BACK IS NEGATIVE.
AND SO WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
DOING WITHOUT A POSITION BEING
PART OF THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS IN THE GUIDANCE OF THE
TO THE PATIENT.
IS POTENTIALLY PUTTING THEM ON
PREP BEFORE THEY HAVE BUT WHILE
THEY HAVE TURNED POSITIVE BUT
BEFORE A TEST.
INDICATES THAT THERE THAT --
THAT THEY'RE POSITIVE AND THAT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT ELEMENT TO BE
CONSIDERED -- RELATIVE -- TO TO
THIS BILL -- I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT A COUPLE OF THINGS RELATIVE
TO THE THE AMENDMENTS ONE IS --
I THINK IT'S BEEN MENTIONED THE
THE PHARMACIES 'MSELVES
NOT EQUIPPED TO DO THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT THIS BILL NOW
REQUIRES THEM TO DO.
INCLUDING AS MORGAN IS INDICATED
HAVING A PRIVATE PLACE WHERE A
PATIENT A A CONSUMER CAN TALK
WITH THE PHARMACIST ON WHAT THE
HIV TEST RESULTS WERE WHAT IF IT
COMES BACK POSITIVE AND YOU'RE
STANDING THERE A WALL GREENS ARE
THEY GOING TO TAKE YOU INTO A
BACK ROOM SOMEWHERE.
AND HAVE PROVIDE YOU THE
COUNSELLING THAT WE REQUIRE OF
ALL HIV -- TESTING OR OR EXPECT
TO ALL HIV TESTING -- IN THIS
STATE -- ALL THE OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO BE DONE BY
THE PHARMACIST -- UNDER THIS
BILL ALL BEING DONE WHILE TWENTY
PEOPLE ARE STANDING IN LINE
WAITING TO PICK UP THERE --
THEIR FOR FLU MEDICATION OR OR
WHATEVER ELSE THEY MAY BE THERE
I'M THE ONLY OTHER THING I WANT
TO POINT OUT -- RELATIVE TO THE
THIRTY DAY -- WINDOW IS THAT
THERE IS A HOPE OBVIOUSLY IN
THAT AMENDMENT THAT THE THIRTY
DAYS WOULD GIVE THE PATIENT TIME
TO GO TRACK DOWN A POSITION AND
GET APPROVED PHYSICIAN'S
PRESCRIPTION.
I FEAR WHAT'S MORE LIKELY TO
HAPPEN IS THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
WITHIN THAT THIRTY DAYS WHEN
THAT THIRTY DAYS IS UP RATHER
THAN GOING TO A POSITION AS
SENATOR WINNERS INDICATE A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE VERY COMFORTABLE
AND ARE GONNA END UP GOING TO
ANOTHER PHARMACY.
AND THEY'RE GONNA HOP FROM
PHARMACY TO PHARMACY AND GET A
THIRTY DAY PRESCRIPTION -- AT
EVERY PHARMACY THEY POSSIBLY CAN --
AND NEVER -- IT IT ENGAGE THE
SERVICES OF SESSION FOR THOSE
REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED TO JUST INCLUDE HAPPENED
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING OUR
LETTER IN ON TIME IT THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY ON OUR OUR MANDATE
LIST BUT WE JST WANT TO HAVE
SOME CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR -- CLARIFYING THAT DOES
NOT MANDATE OUT OF NETWORK
SERVICES SO.
BOB WEIR POST IN OUR THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS DEMAND REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCER WITH AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBGYN IS JUST AT NIGHT
IN OPPOSITION.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA BRING THE ISSUE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND NOT COMMENTS AND
BEFORE WE BEGIN LET ME JUST
MENTION THAT -- BECAUSE THIS IS
HAPPENED ON A COUPLE OCCASIONS
IN OUR BE A SHORT START OF THE
YEAR. FOR ALL YOU FOLKS IF YOU
HAVE OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
LETTERS ARE ABOUT POSITIONS YOU
HAVE TO GET IT IN EARLY.
YOU HAVE TO GET INTO OUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER EARLY AT TO
GET INTO THE AUTHORS OUR OFFICE
EARLY.
THAT'S A THAT'S PART OF HOW WE
WORK WELL TOGETHER CIVIL A IS --
DON'T SURPRISE PEOPLE.
AT YOUR POINT OF YOU OUT THERE
SO WE CAN ALL BE CONSIDERED.
BOB WILL NOT ON THIS BILL AND
OTHER BILLS THAT WE'RE HEARING
TODAY.
I I GET LETTERS THAT I THOUGHT
WELL WE COULD TRY TO WORK THESE
THINGS OUT BUT IF I DON'T GET
THEM UNTIL THE FRIDAY BEFORE
HEARING.
YOU DON'T GIVE ME REALLY THAT
THE ABILITY TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
AND FIND A PATHWAY I'M SURE THE
AUTHORS -- WOULD FEEL THE SAME
SO THAT'S MY LITTLE GRATUITOUS.
WILL OBSERVATION I HOPE
EVERYBODY WILL WORK HARD -- TO
LET AUTHORS NOW AND LET THE
COMMITTEE KNOW ABOUT POSITIONS
ON ON BILLS AS EARLY AS YOU CAN.
OKAY I SEE CENTER LAID HIS HAND
UP PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CARE.
CENTER WINNER I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
I THINK THAT SOMETIMES PEOPLE --
MIGHT LOOK AT THIS BILL AND
THINK IT IS IS -- JUST AS
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
BENEFIT THE GAY COMMUNITY BUT WE
I'VE HAD AT LEAST ONE IN
PARTICULAR A WOMAN IN MY
DISTRICT WHO WAS RAPED.
AND SHE WAS TOLD THAT THE PERSON
THAT RAPED HER HAD HIV THAT THEY
LET HER KNOW THAT AND SHE HAD A
TERRIBLY HARD TIME.
BEING ABLE TO GET THAT THE PRESS.
THEY GET THAT RIGHT PRESS YES
SORRY.
SORRY THANK YOU -- SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS PEOPLE IN
ALL COMMUNITIES IT AFFECTS MEN
IT AFFECTS WOMEN AND IT'S REALLY
ABOUT ACCESS THE WAY I SEE IT WE
ALWAYS WANT PEOPLE TO GO TO THE
DOCTOR WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING GOOD MEDICAL
ADVICE.
BUT IF THIS CAN HELP PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF AIDS I'M ALL FOR IT
THANK YOU FOR REFORMERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND SIR WIENER I
APPRECIATE -- OPTING INSTEAD TO
CHAT AS WELL -- FOR SO JUST AS
CLEAR FIGHT AT THE FOR IT IS ANY
PHARMACIST CAN WRITE THIS EARLY
PHARMACIST THE WENT THROUGH A
CERTAIN TRAINING.
THIS WILL BE FOR ALL PHARMACISTS --
THERE IS SOMETHING CALLED
ADVANCED PRACTICE FAR RIGHT AS
WHICH CONSTITUTES 1% OF
PHARMACISTS INSTEAD CALIFORNIA --
SO THAT WOULD PROBABLY -- MAKE
THE BILL BORDERLINE NOT WORTH
DOING IF 99% OF PHARMACISTS ARE
UNABLE TO ACTUALLY PROCESS OKAY
SO BASICALLY ANY PHARMACIST
ABOUT TO GO TO TRAINING.
OKAY SO.
HOW MUCH TRAINING THE ON THE THE
END OF THE THE ADMINISTRATIVELY
THAT WILL BE WORKED OUT?
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO MICROMANAGE
WHAT THE TRAINING AS BUT IT IT
DIRECTS AGENCIES.
TO OKAY WELL I GUESS I GUESS
WE'LL BUT CERTAINLY -- I THINK
ONE OF THE GOALS OF YOUR BILL
WHICH I SHARED WE WATCH I
IMPROVE ACCESS PARTICULARLY TO
THE TOP PART I THINK WHEN I TALK
LOW TO BOTH THE GUYS BUT YEAH
YEAH I KNOW YOU'RE RIGHT WORDS
RIGHT OUT YEAH SO -- BUT I AS
YOU POINTED OUT THE AND GET AND
THE DOES SPEAK TO EXACTLY HOW
MUCH TRAINING WOULD BE INVOLVED.
AND I'VE NOT LOOKING TO
MICROMANAGE BEGINNING A SENSE OF
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF PHARMACISTS.
WILL.
DECIDED TO USE TO DO THAT
TRAINING RIGHT SO IS THAT THEN
BECOMES THE UNIVERSE'S
PHARMACISTS WHO'D BE WHO.
TO WHO TO BE ALLOWED TO PROVIDE
THESE MEDICATIONS CORRECT.
YES YES OKAY YEAH WE'LL HAVE TO
IMPORTANT AND AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT STATE CALIFORNIA WILL BE
ABLE.
TO IMPLEMENT IT WE WE MIGHT BEEN
ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES.
INCLUDING AROUND HIV AND I'M I'M
CONFIDENT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THIS.
OKAY WELL RIGHT SO SO ONE PART
IS IS THIS IN TERMS OF OUR THE
THE ACCESS PART THEN I GUESS THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAVE -- IS --
SO THAT IT DIDN'T IN THE BILL
AND I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT.
AND I THINK WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
THE NEED TO LINK WITH THE
PHYSICIAN.
RIGHT FOR THE PHYSICIAN SO RIGHT
NOW IF YOU YOUR PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN YOU SEND THE
INFORMATION THERE BUT THE PERSON
DOESN'T.
AND IF THEY DON'T IF THEY DON'T
HAVE ONE THE PHARMACISTS JUST
PROVIDES THEM A LIST.
AND AND I GUESS.
IT TO ME FOR FOR SOME OF YOU DO
A LOT IF YOU ORDER SAID ATTESTS
OKAY YOU'RE GONNA GET SOME
RESULTS BACK.
BUT IT MAY NOT NECESSARILY HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO THEY ALSO MAYBE
IT HAS SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE
PROPER TO PAT BUT YOU'RE DOING
YES AT A CAN YOU TELL US IN MAY
SHOW SOMETHING ELSE RIGHT AND
AND AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE
SOEONE WHO CAN INTERPRET.
THOSE TASKS AND BABY DECIDE WELL
MAYBE THAT PATIENT NEEDS MORE
FOLLOW UP AND MAYBE IT'S NOT
EVEN ABOUT.
PROPER BABBITT'S ABOUT.
SOMETHING CAME UP RATE -- SO --
SO IN MY MIND.
ANY WOULD BE GOOD IF THE
PHARMACIST ACTUALLY HAD A
RELATIONSHIP WITH A PHYSICIAN OR
A GROUP OF PHYSICIANS.
TO WHO THEY'RE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH BEYOND JUST LIKE I'M ON A
LIST ALL RIGHT -- BUT WHO WOULD
ACTUALLY.
PERHAPS MEET WITH THE PHARMACIST
GO THROUGH THE LAB RESULTS
THEY'VE ORDERS -- TRADE IF THERE
IF THERE'S PATIENTS WHO NEED
PARTICULAR ATTENTION.
SO BECAUSE IT'S MORE I MEAN I
REALIZED DON'T WANT CERTAINLY
THE GOAL OF THE BILL IS TO TRY
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO THESE
MEDICATIONS TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF HIV.
BUT WE ALSO TO REALIZE PEOPLE
AND ONE OF THINGS THAT -- AND
PART OF CDC GUIDELINES WHICH I
DID REVIEW -- HAS TO DO WITH THE
WE HAVE RISING RATES OF STDS --
BECAUSE SOMETIMES PEOPLE AREN'T
USING CONDOMS BECAUSE THEY
FIGURE JUST GOT PROTECT THAT
RIGHT THERE'S OTHER BEHAVIORAL
THINGS THAT AND THEN YOU COULD
PICK UP YOU MEAN PICK UP CERTAIN
THINGS -- FROM THE TESTS THAT
YOU DIDN'T KNOW IT ESPECIALLY IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A REGULAR SOURCE
OF PRIMARY OF REGULAR CARE SO.
I A ONE BE SURE RETURN WE'RE NOT
JUST SAYING WELL ALL ALL WE CARE
ABOUT IS THE AND I KNOW THAT'S
NOT YOUR ATTENTION IS THE HIV
PORTION BUT THESE OTHER LARGER
ISSUES.
THAT GET TIGHT END AS WELL AS
ENSURING WE HAVE THE PROPER
INTERPRETATION OF THE SCREENING
TESTS AND STUFF LIKE THAT IS
PART OF THE CDC PROTOCOL I MEAN
IT'S AND IT'S IT'S SO.
THE IDEA OF COURSE WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THINGS OTHER
THAN HIV AND RENO FUNCTIONS AND
POOR AND THEN -- TESTING FOR THE
MEDIA AND GONORRHEA AND SYPHILIS
IS IMPORTANT AS ARE ALL REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS BUT I ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE --
PUTTING EVERYTHING IN CONTEXT I
AM -- MUCH MUCH MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT SOMEONE BECOMING HIV
POSITIVE AND BEING POSITIVE FOR
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES.
THEN I I MEAN OF COURSE I DON'T
WANT ANYONE TO GET GONORRHEA.
CHLAMYDIA -- THERE IN DIFFERENT
UNIVERSES IN TERMS OF THE HEALTH
IMPACT ON SOMEONE'S LIFE.
THE RISK OF RENAL PROBLEMS WITH
CRAP IS EXTREMELY LOW IT EXISTS
AND THAT'S WHY WE EVERY SIX
MONTHS YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO THE
THE BLOOD WORK.
ON BUT IT IS IN TERMS OF
BALANCING -- I THINK -- AND WE
PUT CONSTRAINTS IN HERE THAT YOU
THAT'S WHY YOU CAN ONLY GET THE
THIRTY DAYS -- AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO STAY HIV NEGATIVE AND AND THE
REALITY IS THAT IN THE SYSTEM WE
HAVE NOW.
REPORT OF REQUIRING PEOPLE TO GO
TO POSITIONS OF PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS OF ALL OF THE
STEPS OF PEOPLE TAKE.
WE ARE LOW ON OUR UP TAKE A
CERTAIN AGE ON THE ASIAN SO LET
ME JUST SAID SO.
SO THE E. IF YOU YEAH I'M NOT
SAYING THAT -- WE SHOULDN'T GIVE
A PRIOR OFF AND SO FORTH I'M
SAYING IS THAT.
THE THE PHARMACIST.
WHO ARE DOING THIS?
AT LEAST IN MY MIND SHOULD HAVE
AN ONGOING RELATIONSHIP WITH A
PHYSICIAN ARE A GROUP OF
PHYSICIANS THAT THEY WERE NOT
JUST A LIST THAT THEY'RE HANDING
OUT THAT THEY HAVE THIS.
ON GOING RELATIONSHIP IN TERMS
OF SAYING THAT YOU KNOW IN THAT
POSITION ACCEPT SOME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SO KNOWS I'M
TRYING TO SAY THAT.
OKAY FINE YELLED WE'RE TRYING TO
PROVE ACCESS.
THE PATIENT SHOWS UP AT A
PHARMACY SAYS THAT.
I AM LOOKING THAT THAT BUT THE
AN EXISTING RELATIONS VILLAGE
THERE'S A TEAM GOING ON HERE
RIGHT AND DOESN'T MEAN THAT THAT
WE NOT TALK ABOUT DOCTOR IN THE
PHARMACY WOULD TALK ABOUT
RELATIONS FOR THE BUT THAT THAT
THAT CAN ACT TO CAN BE.
SERVE THERE I'M NOT REALLY BACK
UP BUT EING THE OTHER THE THE
THE MEDICAL PARTNER TO HELP THEM
AND ALSO THAT COULD BE SOMEONE
WHO.
IN TERMS OF TRAINED DENTIST BY
IS THIS SOMEONE WE NEED TO
FOLLOW MORE CLOSELY FOR OTHER
REASONS -- COULD ALSO BE THE
PERSON THEY SAY YOU DON'T YOU
DON'T HAVE A PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR
I'M WORKING WITH THIS POSITION
WHO YOU KNOW SEIZEPATIENT.
SO SO.
TRYING TO FIGURE HOW WE CREATE A
MORE INTEGRATED TEAM BASED
APPROACH APPROCH THAT AS SO
THAT WE CAN TRY TO BE SURE WE
HAVE THE FOLLOW THROUGH I THINK
THAT'S ONE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
THE IS THE FOLLOW THROUGH.
YEAH AND I HEAR YOU AND I'M
GONNA START TO TO TO RESPOND
ALSO BUT I ONE THING I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT.
IS ON AND I'M HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE -- WHAT I WOULD
NOT WANT TO DO IS CREATE A --
APARTMENTS A REQUIREMENT THAT
WOULD EFFECTIVELY MAKE THE BILL
NOT HAVE VERY MUCH APPLICABILITY
RIGHT NOW WE HAD THE THERE IS A
MODEL THAT EXISTS YOU HEARD FROM
THE IN THE ME TOO PART OF FROM
THE OWNER AND PHARMACISTS WHO
OWNS MISSION WELLNESS IN SAN
FRANCISCO -- WHICH IS A A
PHARMACY WHERE THEY HAVE DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP WITH PHYSICIANS AND
SO IT'S ONE STOP SHOP YOU CAN GO
IN AND AND GET YOUR FULL BOTTOM
ASTROLOGER BLOOD AND HE GOT ON
THE PHONE WITH THE POSITION AND
SO ON AND SO FORTH.
IT TOOK THEM AMAZING MODEL I
LOVE IT THERE'S ONE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WHILE I WOULD LOVE TO COME
TO A DAY WHERE THAT IS THE MODEL
THAT EVERY PHARMACY IN
CALIFORNIA.
EMPLOYEES -- I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE -- IF WE EVER GET THERE'S
GONNA BE QUITE SOMETIME SO ON I
THINK AND AND CONCEPT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE -- BUT THE THE DEVIL'S IN
THE DETAILS ON HOW WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT SETTING
UP OUR PHARMACIES FOR FAILURE IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THIS LAW BUT ALL.
THE REST AUTHORED TO TO TO
RESPOND AS WELL.
THANK YOU -- I WAS ACTUALLY
GOING TO SAY I THINK THAT THIS
IDEA OF THERE BEING
COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN PHARMACIES
AND PROVIDERS IS ACTUALLY FAIRLY
WELL ESTABLISHED AND AS A
PHYSICIAN WHO YOU KNOW HAS LIKE
TEN FIFTEEN MINUTE VISITS I I
REALLY VALUE.
THE FACT THAT THERE'S SOMEONE
ELSE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT CAN
YOU KNOW STAY IN TOUCH WITH MY
PATIENTS THAT CAN STAY IN
COMMUNICATION WITH ME.
AND IN FACT I THINK THAT THAT'S
ONE OF THE VERY EXCITING THINGS
ABOUT THIS THAT REALLY IS
PROMOTING EFFICIENCY AND A TRULY
TEAM BASED MODEL LIKE YOU'RE
SAYING -- AND I DO THINK THAT
YOU KNOW WITH THE WITH THE
TRAINING THAT WILL BE PROPOSED
THAT IT WILL BE STANDARDIZED IT
WILL TRAIN THE PHARMACIST TO
RECOGNIZE YOU KNOW WHAT IS A
NORMAL AND IN THEIR APPROPRIATE
STEPS TO FOLLOW UP -- AND THEN
ALSO I WANTED TO ALSO MENTION TO
SENATOR MADE HIS POINT I THINK
THAT WOMEN.
HAVE BEEN VASTLY YOU KNOW REALLY --
SORT OF IN THE SHADOWS AND I AND
I THINK THAT -- FOR FOR PEPIN
PREP ACCESS IT'S EVEN YOU KNOW
THAT MUCH MORE IMPORTANT AND I
IF YOU THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE
ARE.
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO REDUCE YOU
KNOW PERINATAL HIV TRANSMISSIONS
FOR MANY YEARS NOW AND WE KNOW
THAT WE'RE JUST STILL NOT WHERE
WE WANT TO BE -- CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS IS ALSO AN ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIANS I THINK WITH PREP
IF ANYTHING IT HAS REALLY
ENCOURAGED ALL OF US TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF SCREENING AND I
REALLY THINK THAT THAT WILL
HAPPEN.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A THAT SOUNDS
LIKE US THERE ARE GOOD THINGS.
WORK FOR ONE TALKING ABOUT OKAY
WELL I UNDERSTAND AND CAN WE
WANT TO SEE THE EXACT.
PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT YOU CAN
IMAGINE IT BEING IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FORMS OF SONG.
THUNDERING ON WELL I'M NOT I I
DON'T HAVE AN AMENDMENT SAYING
INSIGHT ON THIS OR ELSE I MEAN I
I THINK WE'RE CONCEPTUALLY
SOUNDS LIKE I HOPE FOR COULD BE
IN THE SAME PLACE AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE I THINK THE
COMMITTEE MINUTES CERTAINLY IF
IMPROVE THE BILL.
A LOT.
TOO THANK YOU SENATOR PAT.
ALL RIGHT.
THE SENATE ABOUT WINTER BEFORE I
LET YOU CLOSE AT MUSIC COUPLE
THINGS FIRST THANK YOU TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF AND AND MANY
WONDERFUL SUPPORTERS FOR WORKING
WITH ME AND AND MY STAFF.
ON THE BILL I WANT TO THANK THE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND OTHERS.
WHO RAISED CONCERNS THAT --
THERE ARE THERE ARE -- WISDOM
AND INSIGHT I THINK IS --
BROUGHT US TO A PLACE WHERE I
THINK THE BILL IS IN.
MUCH BETTER SHAPE FROM OUR POINT
OF VIEW AND IT'S WHY IT IT JOYS
MY SUPPORT -- BUT I WANT TO SAY
A COUPLE THINGS ONE IS IS THAT
NONE OF US WANT TO GET.
IN THE WAY OF THE PATIENT
PHYSICIAN INTERACTION -- THAT
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO AND
IF WE COULD -- SNAP OUR FINGERS
AND MAKE THAT HAPPEN YOU KNOW WE
WOULD WE WOULD SNAP OUR FINGERS
AND INSTEAD -- THERE ARE SOME
WHO LOOK AT BILLS LIKE THIS AND
SAY THIS IS A SCOPE ISSUE WORST
GO FIGHT.
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS
ANYTHING NEAR THAT AS IT RELATES
TO ME.
THAT IF THE FOCUS REALLY SHOULD
BE ABOUT -- THE PATIENT HEALTH
AND SAFETY FUNDAMENTALLY.
AND IS NOBODY DISAGREES WITH THE
GOALS REALLY ABOUT HOW YOU GET
THERE.
AND FOR ME WHAT WAS MOST
PERSUASIVE IN TERMS OF THIS
LEGISLATION WITH AS AMENDED IS
THAT.
WE WE WE STILL STAY VERY FOCUSED
ON THE CDC GUIDELINES AND ALL
THAT THIS BILL PROVIDES.
I THAT IN REGARD TO PAP WE'RE
DEALING WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
CRISIS IN A IN A MOMENT OF
CRISIS -- AND IT JUST MAKES NO
SENSE TO TRY TO CREATE BARRIERS
IN FACT WE SHOULD BE DOING THE
OPPOSITE WHICH IS THIS BILL
PROVIDES.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE DO PUT
SOME PARAMETERS ON THAT MOMENT
OF CRISIS -- A A A A FULL THIRTY
DAY OR TWENTY EIGHT DAY --
SUPPLIED TO HELP.
TAKE CARE OF THAT CRISIS WITH
THE STRONG ENCOURAGEMENT.
THAT THEY SEE A PHYSICIAN AND
THAT THEY CREATE THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT SENATOR PAN
YOU AND OTHERS OF HAVE MADE A
POINT ABOUT.
SO -- AND AND WE PUT LIMITS ON
IT SO THE THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM I THINK PROVIDES
FOR THAT IMMEDIATE HELP --
SENSITIVITY TO THAT MOMENT OF
CRISIS -- AND AND ADHERENCE TO
THE CDC STANDARDS ABOUT HEALTH
CARE -- IN THE EIGHT
MINISTRATION OF THAT.
THAT DONE MEDICATION -- AND
REGARD TO PREP.
AGAIN WHO WOULDN'T WANT TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION THAT FULL
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATION TAKE
INCORPORATE MANY MORE THINGS
THAN JUST HIV -- BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE HAVE TO BE PRAGMATIC AND
AND GIVEN OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE CDC GUIDELINES AND THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH AN IMMEDIATE
COURSE OF PROP.
I THINK IT IT WAS PERSUASIVE TO
ME THAT THIS BILL.
UP PROVIDES THAT CAREFUL BALANCE --
TERMS OF PATIENT HEALTH -- AND
AND OVERALL HEALTH STANDARDS --
TO TO MAKE THIS A VERY
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS POINT AND%
CENTER WE WIENER CONGRATULATIONS
TO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS AREA.
IT'S NOT EASY THESE ARE TOUGH
TOUGH ISSUES BECAUSE OF THE
BALANCING ACT THAT REQUIRES BUT
I THINK THAT YOUR BILL.
AS AMENDED PROVIDES FOR THAT AND
HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
CENTER WE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THE FOR
THE CONVERSATION TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD.
A ONE THING I DO JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT -- SO SO THERE'S NO
CONFUSION -- UNFORTUNATELY I WAS
SURPRISED THAT I SHOULD NOT
SURPRISE THAT ONE OF THE
ORGANIZATION SITTING AT THIS
TABLE OPPOSED THE BILL.
WAS AN ORGANIZATION CALLED AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IT'S VERY
CONFUSING TO MEMBERS I KNOW IN
THIS BUILDING BECAUSE PEOPLE
TALK TO ME ABOUT IT WHY IS AN
HIV ORGANIZATION OPPOSING A BILL --
DESIGNED TO REDUCE HIV
INFECTIONS YOU'LL SEE FROM THE
SUPPORT LESS BUT OUGHT TO THE
CREDIBLE HIV ORGANIZATIONS CITY
CALIFORNIA ARE SUPPORTING AND
SPONSORING.
OF THIS BILL IT'S HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION HAS BEEN A OVER TIME
A STAUNCH OPPONENT OF PROP HAS
RUN ADVERTISING CAMPAIGNS TO
DISPARAGE PROP.
IN CONTRADICTION OF THE ENTIRE
REST OF HIV ADVOCACY COMMUNITY --
SO I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THE
CONTACTS SO THAT NO.
ONE CONFUSED ABOUT WHY WOULD YOU
HAVE IT AN ORGANIZATION THAT
SAYS ITS FIGHTING FOR PEOPLE.
LIVING WITH HIV IN TRYING TO
PREVENT HIV COMMENTED OPPOSE A
BILL LIKE THIS -- BUT OUR
COLLEAGUES I DO APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AND I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT MISTER CHAIRMAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIBEL.
VERY GOOD LOOKING FOR A MOTION
FROM THE COMMITTEE SENATOR HILL.
THIS HAS MOVED THE BILL AS
AMENDED THE SECRETARY WOULD CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE CHIANG
[inaudible]
LETTER.
DODD I THOUGHT I GALGIANI THE
CHANTING AYE HILL HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN.
WILK HI OKAY CENTER THAT BILL
CURRENTLY HAS ENOUGH SUPPORT TO
GET OUT OVER A HOLDEN ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH REGULATIONS.
RIGHT.
NEXT ON OUR AGENDA IS THAT SB
ONE NINETY THREE SENATOR NIELSEN
WELCOME TO UP THE ANTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS PATIENTS
TODAY.
THE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THIS.
ISSUE WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION BY ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS OF MISTER PATRICK
BRIAN [inaudible]
HIS SON.
IN THE SMOKE SHOP.
OUR TOBACCO SHOP.
BEGAN TO USE NITROUS OXIDE
[inaudible]
THESE.
THIS NITROUS OXIDE IS CONSUMED.
IN A CANISTER.
LOOKS LIKE A SMOKING CANISTER
BUT IT IS MODIFIED OR BY THEN.
THE NITROUS OXIDE CANISTER CAN
BE ATTACHED.
THE INDIVIDUAL THEN IN JEST
[inaudible]
THAT.
LARA NITROUS OXIDE.
THEN IT'S DANGEROUS.
MISTER BRYANT SON SHANE.
WAS HOSPITALIZED HOSPITALIZED
AND HE DID RECOVER [inaudible]
ANOTHER HALF.
WOMAN NAMED BARBARA.
SON HAD THE SAME.
DIFFICULTY SHE FOUND TWO HUNDRED
OF THE CANISTERS [inaudible]
ANDERSON'S POSSESSION.
HE WAS USING UP TO THAT MANY.
IN A DAY ALL.
IT'S A IN THE MEDIA AS I
UNDERSTAND IT HI.
AND IT DOES HAVE LONG LASTING
EFFECTS [inaudible]
THE BRAIN.
ENTER YOUR LIVES.
THE CONCERN IS THAT THESE ARE.
AVAILABLE IN.
TOBACCO.
OR SMOKE SHOPS.
AND IT WAS.
DISTURBING TO ME. ONE OF MY
STAFF WANTED TO GET A BOX OF
THESE CANISTERS SO.
WE COULD DISPLAY IT TO THE LAST
COMMITTEE.
WHAT THE CANISTER LOOKS LIKE
[inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
ENQUIRING.
WHOEVER WAS WAITING ON HER SHE
SAID ARE YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
FOR ME.
LIKE MY HEALTH FOR MY AGE -- AND
ANY QUESTIONS.
AND THE PERSON SAID NO.
BUT DON'T YOU WANT TO BUY A
LARGER SUPPLY [inaudible]
WELL.
NOW THAT'S ONLY ONE INSTANCE.
ANECDOTAL.
BUT I'D CONSIDERED SERIOUS.
WITH THIS LEGISLATION WE'RE
MAKING IT ILLEGAL FOR AN ONLY.
TOBACCO AND SMOKE SHOPS.
THIS BOOK WILL ONLY TO THOSE
LOCATIONS.
THIS WILL BE A MISDEMEANOR.
AND THE INDIVIDUAL COULD LOSE
THEIR BUSINESS LICENSE. FOR THIS
OFFENSE.
PEOPLE HAVE DIED [inaudible]
OVER THIS.
THE CONCERN IS THE SMOKE SHOPS
ARE SO INNOCENT.
DO YOU GO IN THERE.
EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO THESE
SMOKE SHOPS [inaudible]
AND YOU CAN SEE HOW ONE WOULD
JUST SWEET WORDS.
COULD PROBABLY PROMOTE
[inaudible]
THE SALE.
THESE FIGHTERS OXIDE CANISTERS
AND THE ATTACHMENTS THAT COME
[inaudible]
THE DEVICE [inaudible]
IT'S A INDUSTRIAL CREAM
DISPENSER WHICH IS A VERY
COMMONLY USED DEVICE.
WHICH MAKES IT ALSO SEEM MORE
INNOCENT.
BUT TO ATTACH THEIR TO ARSON
TUBES IN BALLOONS.
AND THAT'S WHERE THEY THEN
INGEST.
THIS NITROUS OXIDE.
SO I WOULD ASK THE INDULGENCE OF
THE COMMITTEE AND I DID NOT
BRING THOSE WITNESSES AGAIN
TODAY I'VE JUST DECIDED WHAT
THEY PRESENTED IN THE LAST
HEARING.
BUT I DO BELIEVE IT IS A SERIOUS.
CONCERN IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WE OUGHT TO MAKE IT IS
UNAVAILABLE.
AND AS DIFFICULT AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU CENTERNIELSEN ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN A AND
SUPPORT THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME
UP.
ARE ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
I SEE NOW WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK
FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
I SEE.
I SEE CENTER RADFORD'S ARRIVE
CENTER WELCOME THANK YOU LIKE TO
CALL YET TO PRESENT SB FIVE
NINETY FIVE GREAT TIMING MY
FRIEND.
THANK YOU.
AND FIRST LET ME THANK YOUR
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN ANALYSIS
AND I WANTED STATE THEN I'M
ACCEPTING THEY'LL AMENDMENTS.
SB FIVE NINETY FIVE WHICH WILL
ENABLE INDIVIDUALS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES PARTICIPATING
CALIFORNIA'S LEGALIZE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY.
SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE NINE FIVE
WILL HELP ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF
CREATING THAT KNOCKED THE BALL
INDUSTRY.
MARK CORN STATE LICENSING
AUTHORITIES TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM TO PROVIDE A
FEEDER FOR ALL OR WAIVE THE FEE
TO OBTAIN OR RENEW A STATE
LICENSE FOR LOCAL EQUITY.
APPLE APPLICANTS IN LICENSEES.
CITIES SUCH AS OAKLAND SAN
FRANCISCO LOS EARNED IN
SACRAMENTO HAVE CREATED THEIR
OWN EQUITY PROGRAMS WAS FOCUS ON
INCLUSION IN SUPPORT APPLICANTS
THAT HAVE.
BEEN MOST HARMED BY THE DECADES
DECADES LONG A LONG WAR ON DRUGS
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE GOVERNOR SIGNED MY BILL
SB NINE THREE TWELVE NINETY FOUR
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS EQUITY
ACT WHICH PROVIDED FUNDING
THROUGH THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO A STOP TO EQUITY PROGRAM.
SB FIVE NINE FIVE BILLS UPON OUR
WORK LAST YEAR TO PROVIDE TO
DIRECT SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS
ACROSS THE STATE FACING THE
TOUGH AS BARRIERS TO ENTRY.
THE COST OF AN APPLICANT TO
SECURE A STATE CANNABIS LICENSE
CAN REACH TENS EVEN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
[inaudible]
OFFER THOSE.
THAT MAY BE OUT I'M SORRY FOR
THOSE THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
OPERATING PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE
OF PROPS SIXTY FOUR A BEEN A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTED BY THE
CANNABIS PROHIBITION THESE COSTS
ARE INSURMOUNTABLE SO.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH
CALIFORNIA'S ALWAYS BEEN THE
NATIONAL LEADER ON A MANY ISSUES
AND WHILE WE'RE NOT THE FIRST
STATE TO LEGALIZE ADULT USE
CANNABIS WE ARE ON THE CASA
BEING THE FIRST STATE TO DO IT
RIGHT.
BY INCLUDING THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
MOST IMPACTED BY PREVIOUS
POLICIES THAT HAVE FAILED ENTIRE
SEGMENTS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY SB FIVE NINETY
FIVE WILL HELP GROW OLD TO ME I
SHOULD SAY WILL HELP GROW AND
AND DIVERSIFY CALIFORNIA'S
CANNABIS INDUSTRY IN SUPPORT
DEVELOPMENT A SMALL BUSINESSES.
BENEFIT COMMUNITIES DEVASTATED
BY PROHIBITION INCREASE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY BY ENCOURAGING
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
OPERATING ILLEGALLY TO ENTER THE
LEGAL AND REGULATED MARKET WITH
ME TODAY AS PROCEED A COULD YOU.
ATTORNEY FOR THE MINORITY
CANDIDATES BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
I WANT THANK IN ADVANCE AND ASK
FOR YOUR AYE AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
HONORABLE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME -- TO Là HERE FROM THE
MINORITY CAMPUS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE THE FIRST NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR REGULATED CAMPUS
BUSINESS OPERATORS FROM MINORITY
COMMUNITIES -- NCBA STRONGLY
SUPPORTS SB FIVE NINETY FIVE AND
ASKS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
OUR INDUSTRIES MINORITY
ENTREPRENEURS CONTINUE TO
COMPETE ON A VERY UNLEVEL
PLAYING FIELD.
THIS IS THE RESULT OF DECADES OF
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN THE ARREST
AND PROSECUTION OF CANNABIS
OFFENSES.
THESE DISPARITIES OF NOT ONLY
HARM THOSE WHO ARRESTED
PROSECUTED INCARCERATED BUT IT
ALSO GREATLY CHILL PARTICIPATION
IN THE INDUSTRY BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR GENERALLY.
SUCH THAT THEY RARELY EVER ENJOY
A FIRST MOVER ADVANTAGE IN THE
NEARLY REGULATED CANVAS STATE
CAMPUS MARKETS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE IN
INDUSTRY CURRENTLY DOMINATED BY
WELL ESTABLISHED PLAYERS WHO
WERE NOT AFFECTED BY SUCH
DISPARITIES.
AND ENTERED THE INDUSTRY EARLY --
BEFORE THE PASSAGE OF
LEGALIZATION AND REGULATION.
AS A DRUG POLICY ORGANIZATIONS
SUCH AS THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
HAVE SHOWN THESE DISPARITIES ARE
NOT MERELY PERCEIVED BUT ACTUAL
EVIDENCE BY HARD DATA.
ALSO WHEN COMBINED WITH THE
CONTINUED FEDERALLY LEGALITY OF
CANNABIS THESE DISPARITIES MAKE
AN ALREADY TOUGH BUSINESS THAT
MUCH TOUGHER FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR
TO BREAK INTO. FOR EXAMPLE BANKS
OTHER SOURCES OF BUSINESS
CAPITAL ARE GENERALLY
UNAVAILABLE TO MOST INDUSTRY
ACTORS.
THIS LACK OF ACCESS TO CAPITAL
IS EXACERBATED FOR ENTREPRENEURS
OF COLOR BY THE STIGMA IN FEAR
CREATED BY DECADES OF UNEQUAL
ENFORCEMENT SUCH THAT EVEN
SOURCES OF CAPITAL NORMALLY
AVAILABLE TO MINORITY BUSINESSES
SUCH AS FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
ARE NOT AVAILABLE DUE TO
JUSTIFIABLY HEIGHTEN FEARS OF
INCARCERATION ASSET FORFEITURE
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
FINALLY BEGIN THE HIGH COST OF
STATE LICENSING AND RENEWAL FEES
CREATE AN ADDITIONAL IMPEDIMENT
THAT THREATENS TO PREVENT MOST
MINORITY CAMPUS BUSINESSES FROM
GETTING BEYOND A BUSINESS PLAN.
AND LODGING LAWFUL OPERATIONS
THAT CAN COMPETE ON A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD WITH OTHER
CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
WHY THESE FEAR WHILE WHILE THESE
FEES ARE TIERED THEY ARE
COLLECTED FROM PRE REVENUE
BUSINESSES BASED ON EXPECTED
REVENUES AND CAN QUICKLY CLIMB
INTO THE TENS AND EVEN HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS?
AS A SENATOR -- MENTIONED.
ALL THIS CREATES MARKET AND
REGULATORY CONDITIONS WHICH
CONTINUE TO FACILITATE THE
ILLICIT MARKET BY STACKING THE
DECK AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO
WISH TO APPLY FOR CANNABIS
BUSINESS LICENSES. FOR THESE
REASONS NCBA FEELS THAT
MANDATING STATE LICENSING
AGENCIES TO CREATE AN EMPLOYMENT
APPLICATION AND LICENSING FEE
WAIVERS AND DEFERRALS FOR
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS AND
LICENSEES UNDER SO LOCAL SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAMS IS NECESSARY IN
WARRANTED.
THE COUNTER INTUITIVE WE BELIEVE
THESE WAIVERS AND DEFERRALS WILL
ULTIMATELY INCREASE STATE CAMPUS
TAX REVENUES BY ALLOWING NEW
REVENUE GENERATING JOB PRODUCING
BUSINESSES TO GET OFF THE GROUND.
AND COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
CANNABIS PROHIBITION AND
OTHERWISE OPPOSE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF ANY NEW
CANNABIS BUSINESSES THAT DON'T
REFLECT AN HONOR THE POPULATIONS
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES.
ANY DEFERRED LICENSING FEES
WOULD STILL BE PAID THE STATE
LICENSING AGENCIES EXTENDING
THOSE DEFERRALS AND ANY WAIVED
FEES WOULD BE RECOUP TO THE
RESULTING OVERALL INCREASE IN
TAXABLE SALES BY THE SOCIAL
EQUITY BUSINESSES.
THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF THIS BILL
IS THE BILL AN EUITABLE CAMPUS
INDUSTRY OF REFLECTING THE BROAD
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ADDRESSING THE HARMS IMPOSE
DISPROPORTIONATELY UPON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BY
ADDRESSING BARRIERS TO ENTRY
SPECIFICALLY UNEVEN ACCESS TO
CAPITAL AND ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A FAIR CHANCE
OF BECOMING SUCCESSFUL IN OUR
INDUSTRY.
ON BEHALF OF MC BE A WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB FIVE NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESSES SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE SPONSORED
SUPPORTER THANK YOU.
THE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORTING COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE AND INDICATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS ARE MALAKAR ALL MEN
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
URBAN PARTNERSHIP ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL BECAUSE IT
DOES.
ADDRESS THE RACIAL OUT WEALTH
GAPS THAT WERE CREATED BY THE
WAR ON MARIJUANA AND WE THINK
SENATOR BRADFORD FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL TO THE TO THE HOUSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE WE BELIEVE THIS
WILL HELP REDUCE FINANCIAL
BURDENS FOR THESE -- LOCAL
EQUITY APPLICANTS INTO THE LEGAL
MARKET WE THANK SENATOR BRADFORD
FOR HIS CONTINUED WORK IN THIS
AREA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SENATOR PAT.
I THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD I
JUST MAKE NOTE IN THE ANALYSIS
THEY DID MENTION THAT IT'S THERE
ARE CLEAR WHETHER A WAIVER WOULD
BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH.
PROP SIXTY FOUR AND DAVID THE
FOR CAN YOU JUST ADDRESS THAT.
YES -- WE ADDRESS THAT.
THE WAIVERS IN LINE AND THE PROP
SIXTY FOURS INTENTIONS ON
ASSISTING THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
HARMED BY THE WARREN JOB DRUGS
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THAT HAVE BEEN GREATLY IMPACTED
SO.
HELPING WITH FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE WHICH PROP PROP SIXTY
FOUR STATED OF BRINGING THAT
COMMUNITY AND TO THIS SPEAR OF
ENTREPRENEURSHIP THIS WAIVER.
ADDRESSES THAT CONCERN.
OKAY WELL CERTAINLY YOUR SUPPORT
WE TRYING TO DO AND DON'T WANT --
TO DID THAT ALSO HOPE THAT WE
DON'T RENTAL LEGAL PROBLEM THERE
AND THINKING WHAT MECHANISMS
MIGHT PUT IN PLACE TO AVOID THAT
SO YOU CAN STILL KEEP THE
EXACTLY.
YEAH.
AND ANY OF THAT OF HAVING TO
MOVE THE BILL CENTER PAN HAS --
MOVED BILL WITH KNOWLEDGE THAT
MOTION.
AND ASKED SECRETARY TO CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS DUE PASSAGE MENDED
DESCENDED APPROACH.
GLAZER.
HI GLAZER AYE CHIANG
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
DOT HI DODD AYE GALGIANI.
JOHNNY I STILL FEEL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN.
CAN I WILK I WILL GUIDE.
CENTER THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS GRADUATIONS.
NEXT UP BUT THE CENTER JONES
HERE SB.
THREE EIGHTY FIVE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDED ON
PAGE FIVE OF THE COMEDIAN SYSTEM
THINKING TO COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL.
SENATE BILL THREE FIVE MAKE
SEVERAL UPDATES TO THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR ACT TO IMPROVE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
MAINLY THIS BILL UPDATES THE
PHYSICAL LICENSE A PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR RECEIVES FROM THE
BUREAU.
CURRENT LICENSED INVESTIGATORS
MUST HAVE A TRADITIONAL PAPER
LICENSE IT LOOKS MUCH LIKE OTHER
DC LICENSES.
THAT MUST BE POSTED IN PUBLIC
VIEW.
HOWEVER MUCH OF A PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS JOB TAKES PLACE
OUTSIDE OF THEIR OFFICE.
THE BUREAU OF SECURITY ON
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES ALSO
OFFERS A POCKET CARD. TO PRESENT
TO PEOPLE IN THE FIELD.
THIS BILL COMBINES THOSE TWO
LICENSES INTO ONE PORTABLE
LICENSE THE CONTAINS IT
INFORMATION NECESSARY FOR
CONSUMER. TO VERIFY A LICENSE
SUCH AS A PICTURE OF THE
LICENSEE AND THE LICENSES EXTRA
EXPIRATION DATE.
SB THREE EIGHTY FIVE ALSO
REQUIRES THE ONLINE DATABASE TO
BE SEARCHABLE BY AN INDIVIDUAL
PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS NAME.
NOT JUST THE NAME OF THEIR
COMPANY ENSURES THAT THE
PENALTIES FOR ACTING AS A
PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR WITHOUT A
LICENSE ARE CONSISTENT.
THROUGHOUT THE BNP CODE.
THOSE CHANGES WILL HELP BRING
MORE PROTECTIONS TO THE INDUSTRY.
AND I LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THIS BILL ALIGNS WITH THE
UPDATES.
BEING MADE THROUGHOUT THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS.
WITH ME TODAY REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SECEDED
LICENSE INVESTIGATORS FRANCIE
KOHLER AND JERRY DOESN'T.
THANK YOU SENATOR FIRST WITNESS
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M THE PAST PRESIDENT -- A PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS I'M ALSO THE
CURRENT LET'S TEAR -- WE
CURRENTLY HAVE WE TO CURRENTLY
GET TWO CARDS WE GET A PAPER
LICENSE THAT HAS AN EXPIRATION
DATE WE GET A HARD LICENSE THAT
HAS A PHOTO WITH NO EXPIRATION
DATE.
AND PAPER LICENSE OF COURSE
DOESN'T HAVE AN OF PHOTO.
SO FOR US THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
TO PRODUCE OUR IDENTIFICATION
CARD WHEN WE DO OUR WORK WE HAVE
TO CARRY TWO CARDS WITH US.
WE WOULD LIKE ONE CONTEMPORARY
CARD THAT HAD BOTH AN EXPIRATION
DATE AND A PHOTOGRAPH.
SECONDLY THE LICENSE LOOKUP THAT
SENATOR JONES IS TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH BREEZES THAT
WAS ELIMINATED WE USED TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK UP A PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR BY THEIR PERSONAL
NAME?
NOW IT CAN ONLY BE LOOKED AT BY
BUSINESS NAME.
THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR US BECAUSE
MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW OUR
BUSINESS NAMES IN OUR PERSONAL
NAMES THAT'S HOW THEY REFER US
REFERS TO OTHERS.
AND SO WHEN THAT PERSON SAY FOR
ME ATTORNEY GOES TO LOOK TO LOOK
UP MY NAME TO SEE IF I'M
LICENSED.
THEY'RE GONNA ASSUME THAT I'M
NOT BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW MY
BUSINESS NAME.
THEN THE THIRD THING IS --
THERE'S A OUT A LITTLE BIT OF A
A CONFLICT IN THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR ACT REGARDING
[inaudible]
OF ITALY'S FOR UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY UNLICENSED ACTIVITY IS
A PROBLEM.
IT'S A CONSUMER PROTECTION ISSUE
IT'S A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE WE
DEAL WITH VERY VERY PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
AND SO ARE WE WANT THAT CONFORM
TO SO THAT EVERYTHING GREASE OF
THE P. I. ACTING THERE'S NO.
NO CONFLICT THERE AND CHANGING
THE ONE PART OF THAT ACT TO A
MISDEMEANOR INSTEAD OF AN
INFRACTION TO CONFORM WITH THE
REST OF THE ACT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT ONE IS
A CHAIR MEMBERS JERRY DOES MAN
UP HALF OF THE SPONSOR THE BILL
JUST ADD THAT EACH OF THE POINTS
THAT THE THE AUTHOR AND MRS
CILLER MENTION ARE THOROUGHLY
REVIEWED IN THE ANALYSIS AND WE
APPRECIATE.
ALL THE WORK INTO DEVELOPING THE
BUILD UP CONSIDERED IN COMMITTEE
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
YOU CAN STEP FORWARD.
RIGHT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I SEE NOW WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I DON'T SEE ANY BUT I DO HEAR A
MOTION FROM SENATOR [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
NO.
RIGHT I'M AN INTERPRETER IS
MOTION IS. TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS -- YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE CENTER I JUST WANNA READ --
I LIKE THAT TERM CONTEMPORARY --
CARD IN AYE WITHOUT LAST FEW AYE
VOTE.
ALL RIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY BY SENATOR HILL HILL.
H. I. L. L. THE SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL.
GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL AYE HILL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN HI CAN I WILL HI
OKAY UNDER THAT THE BILL ENJOYS
THAT NOW SUPPORT TO GET APPLE
HOLD ROLL UP AND WRAPS.
THANK YOU CAN THANK YOU.
I SEE IS A SEPARATE.
I DO SEE SENATOR VASES HERE
SENATOR.
OUT OF ISSUES HERE FIRST UPS
USING.
SEE THAT'S GREAT DIPLOMACY BEING
WORKED OUT RIGHT.
CENTER BATES WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE SB SIX SEVENTY NINE
ITEM.
ELEVEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND SLAP. FOR HEARING SB SIX
SEVENTY NINE IT SEEKS TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE HELD A
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST.
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER OR
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELOR
LICENSE FOR AT LEAST TWO YEARS
IN ANOTHER STATE TO BECOME
LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THESE LICENSES --
S. MEET ALL EDUCATION AND
SUPERVISED EXPERIENCE
REQUIREMENTS THE BRAND NEW
APPLICANT MUST MEET WHEN THEY
COME TO CALIFORNIA.
EVEN IF THEY HAVE BEEN LICENSE
FOR MANY YEARS OR DECADES IN
THEIR HOME STATE.
THIS NEW PROPOSAL WOULD HONOR
THE EXPERIENCE THEY HAVE AS THE
LICENSEE IN THEIR HOME STATE
WHILE STILL MAKING SURE THAT THE
OBTAIN ADDITIONAL COURSE WORK.
TO TEACH THEM CALIFORNIA'S
SPECIFIC LAWS AND HELP THEM
PRACTICE EFFECTIVELY IN
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE ENVIRONMENT.
THE PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT WITH
THEIR FIRST AT A NATIONAL LEVEL.
TO IMPROVE LICENSE PORTABILITY
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND IS ALSO IN LINE WITH RECENT
RECOMMENDATIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
WITH ME TODAY IS ROSEANNE HELMS
WITH THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCE OF WELCOME.
THANK YOU RISEN HOME SUPPORT
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND TO SENATOR BATES FOR
AUTHORING THE BILL -- SB SIX
SEVENTY NINE IS AN EFFORT THAT
THE BOARD HAS BEEN WORKING ON
FOR SOME TIME -- TO HELP TO MEET
THE INCREASING DEMANDS FOR
LICENSES TO BE MORE PORTABLE
ACROSS STATE LINES -- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS AT A NATIONAL LEVEL WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
BOARDS AND WITH THE NATIONAL
BOARD OF CERTIFIED COUNSELORS
AND ALSO WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPY
REGULATORY BOARDS.
ALL OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
WORKING ON FOR PROPOSALS TO LIFE
INCREASE LICENSE PORTABILITY FOR
LICENSEES ACROSS STATE LINES.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW A
STREAMLINED PATHWAY FOR AN
ACTIVE LICENSE FEE IN GOOD
STANDING FROM ANOTHER STATE TO
BECOME LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY WOULD NEED TO TAKE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY HOURS OF
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC COURSE WORK
AND THINGS LIKE CALIFORNIA LAW
AND ETHICS -- CALIFORNIA
CULTURES CALIFORNIA CHILD ABUSE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS -- THE
BOARD BELIEVES THIS PROPOSAL
STRIKES A GOOD BALANCE OF
INSURING ABILITY PRACTICE THEIR
BILLY RESPONSIBLY AND
EFFECTIVELY IN CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE ENVIRONMENT WITH IT
WHILE STILL HONORING THE
EXPERIENCE LICENSES HAVE AS LONG
TIME PRACTITIONERS ANOTHER STATE.
SEVERAL NATIONAL ASSOCIATIONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE WATCHING
THIS BILL IN ANTICIPATION AND
HOPE THAT IF SUCCESSFUL IT CAN
BE USED AS A MODEL LEGISLATION
FOR OTHER STATES TO USE AS WELL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION THAT THROUGHOUT
THIS PROCESS M..
IN THIS EFFORT FOR THEIR ONGOING
CONTRIBUTIONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. BUT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WHEN THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS QUESTIONS?
HERE -- MOTION NOT CENTER BATES
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE FOR WE
OF VOTE ON THIS WONDERFUL BILL
OF YOURS THANK YOU THANK YOU I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT AS WE
DISCUSS ACCESS TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TO A PROFESSION.
TERMS OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ETCETERA SO ASK FOR YOUR
IDOL THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN HAS MOVED -- TO DO PASSED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR
WOULD CALL THE ROLL GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL BY HILL AYE
LEYVA FIVE IF I PAN HI CAN I
WILK STRONG HIGH WILL CUT.
THE LINE.
CENTER VASE THAT BILLS OUT NINE
ZERO GRADUALLY THANK YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO.
THIS IS A YEAH.
I THIS IS SENATE BILL.
FIVE EIGHTY ONE ITEM SEVEN IN
OUR AGENDA CENTER WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
UP FIRST LET ME THINK THE
COMMITTEE IN THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL IT'S TRULY
APPRECIATED.
AND I WILL BE TAKING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS -- TO
INCLUDE THAT DELAY IN
IMPLEMENTATION -- TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO A TO PROVIDE ONLY THE
CITY COUNTY AND ZIP CODE OF THE
BUSINESS.
AND TO PROVIDE INFORMATION ON
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS THAT OCCUR
AT THE BEGINNING OF LICENSURE ON
THE ISSUE IN REGARDS -- TO
DRESSING THE THEIR CONCERNS
REGARDING THE DISCLOSURE OF
LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT -- ONE
WE WANT TO MAKE VERY SURE THAT
IT IT IT FIFTH SENATE THAT IT
WORKS -- AND TO WERE MEETING
WITH THE APPLICANTS WERE WITH
THE OPPONENTS -- TO TRY TO SEE
IF THERE'S A WAY TO BE ABLE TO
TO FIGURE IT OUT AND OBVIOUSLY
WILL BE IN CONTACT WITH YOU AS
WELL -- AB.
SB FIVE EIGHTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE
THE BEER OF CANNABIS CONTROL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO POST ON THEIR
INTERNET WEBSITE.
OR ON THE CALIFORNIA CAN
CANNABIS PORTAL CERTAIN
INFORMATION ABOUT THE APPLICANT
AND THE LICENSEE THE INFORMATION
THE LICENSING AUTHORITY SHIP
WOULD HAVE TO POST ONLINE -- IS
THE NAY EDGE AS I INDICATED
EARLIER THE NAME LICENSE TYPE
OWNERS THE DATE OF THE
APPLICATION AND THE STATUS OF
THE APPLICATION.
AND IF THE APPLICATION WAS
DENIED FOR LICENSE SEE THE SAME
INFORMATION POSTED FOR AN
APPLICANT AS WELL AS ANY
CRIMINAL CONVICTION THAT OCCURS
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
LICENSOR.
CIVIL PENALTY OR JUDGMENT
RENDERED AGAINST A LICENSEE
RESTRAINING ORDER CITATION OR
FINES ISSUED AND LABOR CODE
VIOLATIONS DISCLOSED IN THE
APPLICATION.
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO
BRING TRANSPARENCY TO THIS NEWLY
LEGALIZED INDUSTRY IN TO PROVIDE
THE PUBLIC.
AND INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS WITH
A CENTRALIZED LIST OF WHO IS
APPLYING FOR CANNABIS LICENSES
AND WHO IS LICENSED IN THE STATE.
THE INFORMATION REQUIRED TO BE
POSTED UNDER THIS BILL IS PUBLIC
INFORMATION UNDER THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT.
AND THE BILL DOES NOT SEEK TO
DISCLOSE ANY INFORMATION THE
COULD NOT BE OBTAINED THROUGH A
PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST.
THE BILL IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
THE AVERAGE CITIZEN MAY NOT
UNDERSTAND HOW TO RECEIVE THE
AFOREMENTIONED INFORMATION.
YOUR PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST AND
WE KNOW THAT LICENSING
AUTHORITIES CURRENTLY PROVIDE
SIMILAR INFORMATION AS REQUIRED
IN SB. EIGHT FIVE EIGHTY ONE FOR
OTHER INDUSTRIES.
ULTIMATELY CALIFORNIA NEEDS
POLICIES THAT CREATED
TRANSPARENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
THIS CITIZENS CAN EASILY ACCESS
FOR THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS ADDRESSED TO THIRTY
CO WITH UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME YOUR
FIRST WITNESS.
THIS SHERMAN. ONE THANK YOU AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK ON
THE BILL AND OF COURSE WILL
THANK DR. FOR INTRODUCING THE
MEASURE MY NAME'S OF ROTARY CLUB
REPRESENTING UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS.
WESTERN STATES COUNTENANCE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
JUST A COUPLE OF POINTS -- FIRST
AND FOREMOST TO YOUR C. W.'S
BEEN INVOLVED.
WITH THIS NATION INDUSTRY FROM
THE BEGINNING SUPPORTIVE
SUPPORTED LEGISLATION SUPPORTED
INITIATIVE. TO LEGALIZE CANNABIS.
AND TO MAKE SURE THATWE'RE
CREATING THE JOBS THAT HAVE THE
GREATEST CENTER LIVING RATHER
LOWER THAT'S FIRST AND FOREMOST
IN YOUR SYLLABUS INTEREST.
THIS BILL IS IS CONSISTENT WITH
THOSE INTEREST -- ALL WE'RE
WE'RE THE BILL TRIES TO IS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED PRESIDENT
TRANSPARENCY TO THE PROCESS GIVE
ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC TO
INFORMATION IT'S IMPORTANT.
FROM YOU IF YOU W. PERSPECTIVE
INFORMATION AS EVERYONE HERE
KNOWS AGENCIES THE THREE
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN LICENSING
OF BEEN OVERWHELMED.
NOT ONLY AN ISSUE LICENSES IN
CONDUCTING INVESTIGATIONS.
EVEN IN THE REVIEW OF TEMPER
LICENSE WILL EXPIRE EXPIRED AT
THE END OF MARCH.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
THOSE AGENCIES FOR A LOT OF THE
RESEARCH IS NOT BEING DONE.
THIS BILL WE HOPE TO ACCESS
INFORMATION BEFORE AND AND
COMPANIES ARE LICENSED AND YOU.
FOR A PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THAT THE
COMPANIES ARE PROPERLY BETTER
DETERRENT.
COMPANIES THAT ARE COMING IN
THAT HAVE EGREGIOUS LABOR
VIOLATIONS ANOTHER TYPE OF
VIOLATIONS AGAIN.
WITH THE GOAL OF TRYING TO RAISE
THE SENATE LIVING AND NOT TO LET
COMPANIES IN THE WORLD.
WE HAVE THE OPPOSITE EFFECT
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT
VOTE THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
FEATURED WAYS OUR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP ROUTE
WITH THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF YOU'RE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF COOLEY OF THE ONE OF
THE LARGEST -- OPERATOR CANNABIS
OPERATORS IN THE STATE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
INS IN SUPPORT.
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE
ARE NOT OFFICIALLY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
AND WE WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
AMENDMENTS -- WE DO YOU --
CONTINUE TO PLEDGE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS AND WE HOPE TO
GET THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AMY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SAME TRACY STEVENS
REPRESENTING NOR CAL CANNABIS
WERE VERY HAPPY TO BE WORKING
WITH SENATOR COVER YOUR AND HOPE
WE CAN COME TO AN AGREEMENT.
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR
ANY BETWEEN HERS.
OKAY WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS -- LET ME SAY
SENATOR -- CARRIER THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR TIME AND THEN YOUR
SPONSORS TIME WITH ME AND THEN
MY STAFF TO TO WORK OUT SOME OF
THESE ISSUES I THINK WE SHARE
THE SAME GOALS -- THAT YOU HAVE --
ARGUED FOR IN THE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU'VE ACCEPTED TO HELP.
PROVIDE THAT SOME SAFETY AND
SECURITY ISSUES THAT.
COME ABOUT BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF THIS INDUSTRY.
AND I ALSO ACCEPT THAT YOU'RE A
COMMITMENT TO WORK ON THE OF THE
LABOR VIOLATION ISSUE SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED WITH AS
WELL AND HOW TO PROPERLY --
RECOGNIZES OUT OF THOSE WHO
MAYBE APPLICANTS AND HOW WE
HANDLE THAT.
EUROPAEA CONTINUED CONVERSATION
WITH THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AS
THE BILL.
MOVES FORWARD SO WITH THAT
BEFORE WE TAKE A VOTE ONCE IF
YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS IT
JUST THE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHTS I SEE A MOTION FROM
CENTER ARCHULETA. TO MOVE THE
BILL THAT WOULD BE -- DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SECRETARY CALDERON
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING I OR TO LET US.
ARCHULETA I DOT.
BUT I GALGIANI YOU CAN SEE ON
THE AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA LIVE AYE PAN HI
CAN I WILL HI OKAY. NINE ZERO
NINE ZERO ALL RIGHT BILLS OUT
NINE ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT NEXT UP AS SENATOR ROTH IS
HE'S ARRIVING AT WE WILL OF ONE
ITEM ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS.
ITEM EIGHT SB FIVE NINETY TWO
THERE ARE MOTION CENTER DOT IS
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL
GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE CHANG
CHIANG I OR TO LET US FOR TO LET
AYE DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
AYE LEYVA THEY'VE AYE PAN.
CAN I WILL HI GUYS ARE THE
CONSENT COUNTIES OUT NINE ZERO
SENATOR ROTH.
SB SIX FIFTY FIVE ITEM TEN IN
OUR AGENDA WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS -- THIS
BILL MAKES.
TECHNICAL ABILITY MAKES NUMEROUS
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND UPDATES TO
PHARMACY LAW IN ORDER TO BRING.
CONFORMITY AN INSURER MNIMUM
COMPETENCY REMOVING BARRIERS TO
LICENSURE AND ALSO SEEKS
ALIGNMENT WITH.
STIPULATED REQUIREMENTS AMONG
OTHER THINGS THE BILL.
INSURERS THAT THE PHARMACY
EXAMINATION IS AN ACCURATE
REFLECTION OF THE CANDIDATES
COMPETENCY AT THE TIME THE
INDIVIDUALS ACTUALLY SEEKING
LICENSURE.
THE LINE'S A RENEWAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR ADVANCED
PRACTICE PHARMACIST WITH THE
PHARMACY RENEWAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT ALLOWS THE BOARD TO ASSESS
FEES.
FROM GOVERNMENT OWNED FACILITIES
REMOVING THE CURRENT SUBSIDY
PROVIDED BY OTHER LICENSED
FACILITIES THE PRIVATE
FACILITIES.
AND IT CLARIFIES THE FEES FOR
UPDATING A LICENSING RECORD AND
FEE TO RE ISSUE.
A PRINTED LICENSE CERTIFICATE --
I HAVE -- AND SO TO GRIN HERE
THE EXACT ABOUT FOR THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS -- WE DO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT WITH RESPECT TO THE
EXTENSION OF THE TIME TO ASSESS
THE OF FEE.
TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE VERY GOOD
SENATOR ROTH [inaudible]
I WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YES.
UP HI ANSWERED A GRIN I'M THE
INTERIM EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF PHARMACY I'D
LIKE TO BOTH THINK SENATOR ROBB
FOR OFFERING THIS MEASURES WELLS
THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
CONSIDERATION.
OF THE BOARD AS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION AGENCY CHARGED WITH
REGULATING THE PRACTICE OF
PHARMACY -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU AND ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER PAT IS MOVE THE BELL
CENTRE RAFI WANNA CLOSE JUSTICE
FOR A VOTE THANKS FOR USING.
CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN.
AND I WILL I WILL GUIDE. NINE
RIGHT CENTRE THE BILLS OUT
NINETY ZERO GRADUATION SITE ON
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE HAVE THREE
BILLS REMAINING ON OUR AGENDA TO
BY SENATOR PAN ONE BY SENATOR
HILL.
SENATOR PAN YOU READY TO GO.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA CALL UP
ITEM THREE SB [inaudible]
THREE THREE FOUR RIGHT.
AT THE END.
RIGHT ALSO OKAY OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER FARE -- MEMBERS
THAT CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING
A SHORTAGE OF CLINICAL LAB
SCIENTIST ACROSS THE STATE
RESULTING A BACKLOG OF
LABORATORY WORK LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED SEVERAL
PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
IN THE ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE SB
THREE THIRTY FOURS A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BILL WHICH WOULD
ENCOURAGE MEDICAL LAB
TECHNICIANS. TO SEEK HIGHER
SKILLED WORK OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS BILL WOULD ASK THE STATE
PARK PUBLIC HEALTH TO ESTABLISH
A NLT MEDICAL LAB TECHNICIAN TO
COS CAREER PATHWAY THE PATHWAY
BETWEEN EXPEDITED PROCESS BY
WHICH A MEDICAL LAB TECHNICIAN --
TO OBTAIN LICENSURE AS A
CLINICAL LABORATORY SCIENTIST BY
ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT
ELIMINATE REDUNDANCIES IN
TRAINING BETWEEN THE TWO
PROGRAMS THE CREATION OF AN
ANIMAL TO THE CLS PATHWAY COULD
POTENTIALLY CUT ONE YEAR OF CLS
TRAINING.
WHICH THE US TRAINING PROGRAM BY
FOUR MONTHS FOR ELIGIBLE
CANDIDATES SB THREE THREE FOUR
WOULD CREE INCENTIVES AND UPWARD
MOBILITY FOR M. L. TEASE TO
TRANSITION TO CLS LICENSURE.
REPLACE THOSE EXITING THE WORK
FORCE AND FILL POSITIONS NEEDED
TO ADD NEEDED DUE TO THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD.
THIS BILL SUPPORT BY LABOR GROUP
CELEBRATORY PROFESSIONALS AM
PLEASED TO HAVE MET BROAD WITH
THE ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
MARCH -- BRASH A CLINICAL
LABORATORY SCIENTISTS AND JAY
DAVIS A MEDICAL LABORATORY
TECHNICIAN TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ANSWERING ECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN WELCOME TO THE
WITNESSES.
IBM CAM MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP
BROUGHT HERE ON BEHALF THAT
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS WHO ARE -- CO SPONSORS
ON THE BILL -- THINK THIS REALLY
QUICKLY THAT I'LL SAY KIND OF
THE IMPETUS FOR THE BILL WAS
TALKING OVER.
WITH OUR MEMBERS THAT YOU KNOW
THEY WANTED THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE UP.
SORT OF A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER IS
THAT WHEN YOU GO TO DO THE
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT OFTEN
PAID ON STATE BEEN OR HOURLY --
AND SO IF YOU ARE SOMEONE WHO
WANTS TO IMPROVE YOURSELF -- IT
AT IT CAN IT CAN BE HARD TO SORT
OF COME TAKE OFF THAT YOUR LONG --
TIME AND AND BE ABLE TO TO BE
ABLE TO AFFORD IT -- I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO DRIVE
HOME THE SB THREE THREE FOUR
DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF THE
EDUCATION OR LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS -- AND THAT YOU
KNOW WE'VE WORKED VERY HARD TO
GET ALL THE OTHER LABOR GROUPS
ON SUPPORT AND AS WELL AS OUR
EMPLOYERS -- WITH ME TODAY SHE
DAVIS SEASON M. L. T. -- HEARING
KAISER SACRAMENTO HE'S GONNA
TALK ABOUT HOW SHE SHE MIGHT%
BENEFIT FROM TAKING PART IN SUCH
PROGRAM [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI AM SHADY THIS -- I'VE BEEN
MOT FOR THREE YEARS -- I'VE
COMPLETED MY PROGRAM PROBABLY
FIVE YEARS AGO AND DURING THAT
TIME.
I HAD TO FINANCIALLY SUPPORT
MYSELF THROUGH MY AND MULTI
PROGRAM AND IT WAS A STRUGGLE --
IT WAS A STRUGGLE TO I STILL
HAVE TO WORK SO THE STRUGGLE TO
GO TO SCHOOL AND TO ALSO WORK --
BUT I MADE IT.
I DO HAVE PLANS TO GO ON FURTHER
FORCE FEEL LESS -- BUT ONE OF
THE BARRIERS IS FINANCIALLY
BECAUSE I STILL HAVE TO WORK I
CANNOT AFFORD.
NOT TO WORK AND TO CUT DOWN SOME
OF THE TIME FOR THE TRAINING AND
THE SCHOOL WILL HELP
TREMENDOUSLY FOR ME -- EL ALL OF
THE THE ROOTS ARE THERE FOR ME
TO GO FORWARD I JUST NEED --
THAT EXTRA HELP THE TANGO -- AND
TO PASS THIS BILL WILL MEAN A
LOT TO ME.
SO I CAN GO AHEAD AND BE A CLS
AND ALSO HELP WITH THE SHORTAGE
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY FOR BEING HERE.
NEXT WITNESS.
HI MY NAME IS MARJORIE BROUGHT
HOME A CLS WHO WORKS AT THE
REGIONAL LABORATORY IT CLOSER --
FROM AN INTAKE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO BE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN MANY
WAYS BECAUSE AT KAISER WE DO
HAVE A CLS PROGRAM.
AND WE ARE CURRENTLY INTO I
THINK OR SIX OR SEVEN TH MLT.
WHO IS GOING THROUGH THE PROGRAM --
AND IS HAVING TO UNFORTUNATELY.
WE DO A LOT OF THE TRAINING THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY DONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THEY BE
ABLE.
TO EXPEDITE THIS PROCESS BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF COS IS.
AND THE NEED FOR MORE.
CLINICAL LABORATORY SCIENTISTS
IN THE CALIFORNIAN CALIFORNIA
AND THROUGHOUT ACTUALLY COUNTRY
WE'RE HAVING A HUGE SHORTAGE
RIGHT NOW AND WE DO YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM.
IN THAT IT'S A FINANCIAL BURDEN
FOR MANY PLACES TO COME UP.
AND PRESENT PROGRAMS AND SO TO
BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE GETTING
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY TRAINED IN
LABORATORY WHO KNOW THIS IS THE
PROFESSION THAT THEY WANT TO
PURSUE. TO CONTINUE WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE TO HELP US
ACCOMPLISH THIS THANK YOU VERY
GOOD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THE FUTURE GLAZER MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
Q..
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS PAT
WHALEN ELIGIBLE SNACK SEE HERE
ON BEHALF OF UNIACKE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DOES THE REALITY OF CW WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANKS
TO HIM.
HELLO CHRISTY FOR WITH THE
CALVARY A CLINICAL LABORATORY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
YES BERBER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF OF
QUEST DIAGNOSTICS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI BOB NUMBER HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SORRY BUT ALL AGES
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THING THAT WILL BRING THE ISSUE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS CENTER
LEYVA.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT I WHAT I
THINK BOTH OF THE LADIES FOR
BEING HERE I USED TO HAVE THE
HONOR OF REPRESENTING CLINICAL
LAB SCIENTIST IN M. L. TEAS.
AND IT WAS ALWAYS A PROBLEM FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU STATED IT
WAS SO HARD TO BECOME A CLS AND
THEY'RE ALWAYS NEEDED SO THANK
YOU DOCTOR PAN FOR BRING THE
BILL FORWARD AD THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
AND WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE ON THE
BILL THE TASTIC.
CENTER PAN I JOIN WITH CENTER
LEYVA AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD IT'S A GREAT.
GREAT WAY TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GROWTH AND
GREATERACHIEVEMENT IN A MORGUE
IN A WAY THAT'S RESPONSIVE TO
THEIR THEIR CURRENT WORK IT'S A
VERY GOOD BILL AMPLY SUPPORTED
TODAY.
THE OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE NOT CENTER PAN WOULD
LIKE TO CLUB I'VE SPENT THE LAST
ONE I HAVE A VERY GOOD SO I MEAN
I RECOGNIZE -- THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
UPDATED THIS GROUP HERE.
CENTER LEYVA FOR YOUR MOTION.
WELL DONE TO THIS IS A THIS IS
DUE PASS [inaudible] TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
YEAH SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
GLAZER.
I THESE ARE AYE CHANGE.
TING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D DOT.
I GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL I FEEL I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN.
AND I WILL I WILL GUIDE.
BY THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS.
OKAY SENATOR PAN YOU HAVE ITEM
SIX SB [inaudible]
FOUR EIGHTY THREE NUMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES HAVE
UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS TAT
DISTINGUISH THEM FROM OTHER
BUSINESSES HOWEVER THERE'S NO
CURRENTLY.
THOSE STANDARDIZED DEFINITION OF
A FAMILY OWNED BUSINESS HAVING A
STANDARD DEFINITION ACROSS STATE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WILL OUT
POLICYMAKERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REFERENCE ONE DEFINE WHAT
DEFINITION ACROSS JURISDICTIONS
AND CODES POLICIES ARE
CONSIDERED.
THE ABSENCE OF A UNIFORM
DEFINITION CREATES DIFFICULTY
AND DETERMINE EXACT MEASURE OF
THE CONTRIBUTION LEASE
POLICYMAKERS WITHOUT ACCURATE
DATA WHEN IMPLEMENTING SPECIFIC
POLICY ISSUES SUCH AS TAX AND
ESTATE SUCCESSION.
SB FORTY THRILLED TO FIND
CALIFORNIA FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES AS BUSINESSES
DOMICILED IN CALIFORNIA IN
OPERATION FOR TEN YEARS OR MORE.
OWNED AND CONTROLLED BY RELATED
PERSONS OR A PARTNERSHIP OF
RELATED PERSONS THAT PASSED THE
BUSINESS THROUGH A GENERATION OR
HAVE A PLAN FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONAL SUCCESSION.
FURTHER THIS BILL OUT WE'LL LET
CALIFORNIA LEAD THE NATION BY
BEING THE FIRST TO STATUTORY THE
FIND A FAMILY OWNED BUSINESS.
THEY ARE PLEASED TO HAVE.
WITH ME DENNIS ALBION HE WITH
THE FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT THE BILL
ALSO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TALK BRANDED EXCELLENT
EXPLANATION OF THE BILL A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT FAMILY BUSINESSES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THE EMPLOY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE DID A SURVEY A
FEW YEARS AGO AND HAD A AN
ANALYSIS -- THE THE WENT THROUGH
AND WE FOUND OUT A FEW
INTERESTING THINGS LIKE.
A FAMILY BUSINESS PROMOTE WOMEN
AT A HIGHER LEVEL TO THE
EXECUTIVE POSITIONS.
ACTUALLY ABOUT A 40% INCREASE
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX OTHER
MORE PHILANTHROPIC LOCALLY IN
THERE THE NEIGHBORHOOD AN
OBVIOUS IS GOOD FOR TAX POLICY
TO HAVE OUR TAX CALIFORNIA OF
CALIFORNIA HEADQUARTERED.
ENTITIES THAT THAT RANGE WITH
BOTH OF IN CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO --
THROUGH OTHER STATES AS WELL SO --
WE APPRECIATE THIS THE BILL WHAT
THIS IS A VERY SIMILAR BILL WAS
WAS PASSED SO WE WILL BE WITH
THE BUT THE ELEPHANT OUT ON THE
TABLE HERE.
HOW WAS VETOED BY US -- GOVERNOR
BROWN -- BACK IN A IT PASSED
THROUGH BOTH HOUSES LEGISLATURE
WITH WITH VERY LITTLE OPPOSITION
ALL.
MAN WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING YOU
KNOW.
INITIATING CONVERSATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR OFFICE TO GO THROUGH
THAT AND AND ENGAGE.
AS WELL AS THE THE PROVISIONAL
SERVICES ON YOU KNOW WHY THIS IS
A GOOD TO HAVE THE DEFINITION
THROUGHOUT THE JURISDICTIONS.
AND SO WE'RE WORKING ON THAT AND
YOU KNOW.
IF YOU TO BE FRANK WE DON'T GET
A POSITIVE SIGN WE WOULD WE
WOULD HOLD BILL BUT OUR GOAL IS.
TO IS TO BRING EVERYBODY FOR
WITH THIS NEW ADMINISTRATION
THANK YOU VERY GOOD ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES.
OKAY LOOKS LIKE THERE ISN'T THAT
THAT'S GOOD SENATOR HILL YOU
HAVE A QUESTION THANK YOU OF
MORE OF A COMMENT I JUST WANTED
TO THANK SENATOR PAN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS THE
OWNER OF A FAMILY BUSINESS --
HERE.
I THINK IT'S IT'S IT'S TIMELY
AND IN EXTREMELY IMPORTANTTO
HAVE THAT DEFINITION PLACE SO
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
PROPER TIME MISTER CHAIR ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
CENTER FAMILY LIKE TO CLOSE.
YOUR FAMILY BUSINESSES ARE --
DIFFERENT IN MANY WAYS AND THAT
SO I EXPECT THE ASSN IVATT.
SO FAMILY BUSINESS OWNER SENATOR
HILL IS MOVE THE BILL.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS FOR GLAZER HI
GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI.
HILL AYE HILL AYE LEYVA.
IF I PAN HI CAN I WILL
[inaudible]
HI.
UNDER THAT CURRENTLY HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET APPLE HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
GRADUATION.
I THINK THAT'S IT -- NO MORE
BILLS LEFT.
OTHERS ONE MORE LEFT.
WE SHARE IS CENTER THINK WE HAVE
TIME.
TO COMPLETE THIS BILL BEFORE WE
BREAK FOR SESSION.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
AND I GUESS IT'LL DEPEND ON US
AND WHETHER WE ASK A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ARE NOT CENTER WILK SO.
KEEP THAT IN MIND.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SO WELCOME UP
SENATOR HILL.
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE ITEM FIVE
CENTER HILL WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT MEMBERS OF VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY --
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES
HOSPITALS CLINICS AND OTHER
HEALTH FACILITIES TO REPORT
ALLEGATIONS OF PATIENT.
SEXUAL ABUSE AND OTHER SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT BY MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO THE APPROPRIATE
STATE LICENSING AUTHORITIES
WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS.
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE CLOSES LEGAL
LOOPHOLES THAT CAN ALLOW A
SUBJECT OF REPEATED TO SEXUAL
ABUSE AND MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS.
TO WORK AT A HEALTH FACILITY FOR
YEARS BECAUSE THE RELEVANT
REGULATORY BOARD IS NOT NOTIFIED
BY THE FACILITY OF THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST A LICENSEE.
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL ABUSE OR
MISCONDUCT BY DOCTORS AND OTHER
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS MUST BE
REPORTED SWIFTLY TO THE
APPROPRIATE LICENSING BOARD FOR
REVIEW SO THAT REGULATORS CAN
DETERMINE WHETHER TO CONDUCT AN
INDEPENDENT.
CONFIDENTIAL INVESTIGATION JUST
BECAUSE AN ALLEGATION IS
REPORTED IN NO WAY MEANS THE
MEDICAL BOARD WILL AUTOMATICALLY
BEGIN AN INVESTIGATION.
ALL COMPLAINTS SENT TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD OUR FIRST REVIEWED
BY A DOCTOR ON STAFF TO
DETERMINE IF FURTHER ACTION IS
EVEN MORE.
TO STATE REGULATORY BOARDS
CANNOT FULFILL THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PROTECT
PATIENTS AND OTHER CONSUMERS.
IF THEY ARE NOT NOTIFIED OF THE
SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS INVOLVING
THEIR LICENSEES.
THE FAILURE TO DO SO SHIELDS BAD
ACTORS WHILE EXPOSING PATIENTS
TO GREATER RISK.
AS YOU ALL ARE ALL FAMILIAR WITH
THE U. S. C. AND DOCTOR TYNDALL
SCANDAL.
WHERE THERE WERE MULTIPLE
COMPLAINTS OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
FOR DECADES?
NONE OF THE PRIOR COMPLAINTS
WERE REPORTED TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD.
THIS IS WHY THE MANDATORY
REPORTING WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD IS ESSENTIAL.
I AM VERY CONCERNED THAT THE CMA.
STATED IN THEIR LETTER OF
OPPOSITION THAT THIS RECALL
REPORTING REQUIREMENT FOR SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS.
ONLY WOULD CREATE YOU SEXUAL
ALLEGATIONS ONLY.
WOULD CREATE AN ENORMOUS I'M
QUOTING AN ENORMOUS
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON ALL
HEALING ARTS LICENSEES AS WELL
AS THEIR RESPECTIVE LICENSING
BOARDS.
EXACTLY HOW MANY OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE BEING BROUGHT
AGAINST THEIR MEMBERS EVERY YEAR
IF IT'S AN ENORMOUS [inaudible]
BURDEN.
IF THERE IS THAT MANY PERHAPS WE
NEED TO SHORTEN THE TIME TO
FIFTH THE FIVE OR SEVEN DAYS TO
REPORT THIS PERHAPS WE SHOULD
LOOK MORE CLOSELY.
AT THE MEDICAL PROFESSION IF MR
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT IS SUCH AN
ENORMOUS PROBLEM AS THEY SAY IT
IS.
NONE OF THE OTHER HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THAT THIS
PROVISION COVERS NONE OF THE
OTHER HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AT
THIS PROVISION COVERS.
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
JUST THE MEDICAL DOCTORS I
HAVEN'T HEARD ANY OPPOSITION
FROM THE NURSES DENTISTS
VETERINARIANS PSYCHOLOGISTS
ETCETERA.
THAT ALSO WOULD HAVE TO COME
THAT WOULD ALSO HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THIS FIFTEEN DAY REPORTING.
TO THEIR RESPECTIVE LICENSING
BOARD.
THOSE PROVISIONS ARE THE SAME.
YOU WILL ALSO HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION THAT SB FOUR TWENTY
FIVE COMPLETELY BYPASSES THE
PEER REVIEW PROCESS.
PUT IN PLACE FOR HOSPITALS.
THIS IS THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
BILL.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT THE EXISTING
PROCESS OF HAVING A PEER REVIEW
SYSTEM TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER THEY SHOULD REPORT IT TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD DOESN'T WORK.
AND IS NOT WORKABLE FOR HEALTH
CLINICS.
ALSO IT DIDN'T WORK FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
WE FINALLY CHANGE THAT IT'S NOW
TIME TO EXPECT THE SAME OF OUR
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WE HAVE
SEEN MULTIPLE EXAMPLES OF
HOSPITALS FAILING TO INVESTIGATE
CREDIBLE ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
THUS PLACING THOUSANDS OF
ADDITIONAL PATIENTS IN HARM'S
WAY.
SEXUAL VIOLATION OF A PATIENT BY
THEIR PHYSICIAN SHOULD NEVER.
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE WILL HELP
ENSURE PATIENT COMPLAINTS ARE
TREATED SERIOUSLY AND
INVESTIGATED WITH THE SWIFTNESS
THEY DESERVE.
MEMBERS WITH RESPECT TO SECTION
FOUR IN THIS BILL SECTION.
FOUR WHICH AUTHORIZES THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO SUSPEND A
LICENSE ON AN EMERGENCY BASIS
PENDING FORMAL PROCEEDINGS.
AS YOU KNOW I CARE VERY MUCH
ABOUT ENSURING THAT ANYTHING WE
DO TO HELP THE MEDICAL BOARD GET
ITS ENFORCEMENT WORKED AND
QUICKLY.
IS STILL DONE IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE DUE PROCESS.
IT'S DEFINITELY NOT MY INTENTION
TO GIVE THE MEDICAL BOARD NEW
UNPRECEDENTED AUTHORITY TO TAKE
ACTION SIMPLY BASED ON
INFORMATION.
I AM WILLING TO STRIKE THIS
PROVISION FROM THE BILL IT'S NOT
MY GOAL TO SKIP ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT REQUIREMENTS.
NOR DO I INTEND TO ALLOW THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO HAVE BROAD
AUTHORITY TO SUSPEND THE LICENSE
WITHOUT PROPER DUE PROCESS.
I HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MISTER HAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
THE INDULGENCE THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER HEALTH.
THE FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS SUSIE CHANGE I AM A
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL
GRADUATE STUDENT OF USC'S
MASTERS OF HEALTHCARE
ADMINISTRATION.
A COST OF TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
AND I AM A SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVOR [inaudible]
SO.
AS A HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL
LIVE WORK TO IN SOME OF THE BEST
HEALTH CARE ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THEY'RE ALREADY COMPLIANT
WITH THE MEASURES SUCH AS
PROPOSED IN THIS AMENDMENT -- I
WANT TO NOTE THAT.
MANY TIMES WHEN SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS ARE MADE ACTUALLY
MOST THE TIME ANSWERS
ALLEGATIONS ARE MADE ABOUT
PHYSICIANS -- INVESTIGATION IS
COMPLETED AND A DECISION MADE
WHETHER OR NOT IT SHOULD BE
REPORTED WITHIN TWENTY FOUR TO
SEVENTY TWO HOURS THESE ARE
TAKEN VERY SERIOUSLY.
AND ALL SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE DOES
IS BRING ALL THE YOUR HEALTH
CARE ORGANIZATIONS IN LINE WITH
INDUSTRY PRACTICES -- WE WE ALL
KNOW THAT USC -- THEY WERE NOT
IN LINE WITH INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICES.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS -- I WAS
ASSAULTED BY GEORGE TYNDALL IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND I SAW
HIM AS A PATIENT -- AND ACTUALLY
WHEN I WENT TO THE CLINIC -- IT
WAS VERY OBVIOUS TO ME THAT --
HIS BEHAVIOR WAS AN OPEN SECRET
ALL THE FRONTLINE MEDICAL STAFF
AT THE RECEPTIONIST'S THE
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE THE NURSES
THEY ALL TRY TO HELP ME.
THEY ALL TRIED TO PREVENT ME
FROM SEEING HIM.
BUT I SIMPLY DIDN'T WANT TO WAIT
THE MONTH IT WOULD TAKE TO SEE --
A FEMALE GYNECOLOGIST AND SO
BECAUSE OF THAT I WAS SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AND ACTUALLY
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE ASSAULT --
THAT'S THAT'S WHEN I SAW
EVIDENCE THAT THEY ALL KNEW WHAT
WAS HAPPENING THEY MANY OF THEM
CALLED AFTER ME AS I RAN OUT OF
THE CLINIC -- THEY THEY SIMPLY
GAVE EACH OTHER A LOOK.
AND ALL OF THESE.
ALL THESE FRONTLINE WORKERS --
KNEW WHAT HAD HAPPENED.
I'M WITHOUT ANYONE SAYING
ANYTHING OTHER AND THEY'LL TRY
TO HELP ME.
AND I BELIEVE IT IS.
BECAUSE OF THESE -- AMBIGUOUS
REGULATIONS THAT USC LEADERSHIP
CHOSE TO IGNORE ALL THE WARNING
SIGNS ON ALL OF THE VARIOUS
REPORTING -- THAT CAME FROM THE
FRONTLINE MEDICAL STAFF.
WE ALL KNOW THAT -- TORSIONAL
INTO PRACTICING -- FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS SING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS -- BECAUSE
NO ONE LEGAL IN THE LEADERSHIP
AT USC TOOK -- ANY OF THE
ALLEGATIONS SERIOUSLY.
USC HAS ADMITTED BY THEIR OWN
COUNT THAT THEY RECEIVED
EIGHTEEN COMPLAINTS -- I'VE SEEN
MANY ESTIMATES THAT PUT THE
COMPLAINT AT A MUCH HIGHER
NUMBER BUT EVEN EIGHTEEN
COMPLAINTS -- USC'S.
SHORTEN NUMBER IS SEVENTEEN TOO
MANY -- SO I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AN **** -- THAT
YOU VOTE YES FOR IT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MYSTERY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY TO SHARE YOUR
STORIES DIFFICULT THAT IT DOES
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU --
MY NAME'S AUDRY NOW SIGUR I WORK
AS A SENIOR DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THE VENTURA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WERE
BEEN FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
I GRADUATED FROM USC LAW SCHOOL
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND I SAW
DOCTOR TYNDALL IN. NINETEEN
NINETY ONE ONE OF THE EARLIER
TELL YOU MY STORY ON A THANK A
SURGERY HOLE FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN PASSING THE PATIENT'S RIGHT
TO KNOW ACT HELP THE HELPING
THAT I THROUGH LAST YEAR AND NOW
THIS BILL AS BEFORE TWENTY FIVE
I BELIEVE IS VERY VITAL.
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT PATIENTS
AND TO BRING ACCOUNTABILITY OF
WHICH WE'VE SEEN NOTHING AT USC
NOT ONE PERSON HAS BEEN HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE'S OVER THERE SEVERAL
HUNDRED WOMEN HAVE COME FORWARD
NOW.
IT'S VERY DISTRESSING.
OF PATIENT SAFETY AND HEALTH
MUST COME FIRST.
AND THE LEGAL LOOPHOLES WHICH
ALLOW DOCTOR TYNDALL TO ABUSE
WOMAN FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS
NEED TO BE CLOSED IN THIS IS A
GOOD TIME TO DO IT.
IF WE LOOK AT OTHER UNIVERSITIES
LIKE MICHIGAN STATE.
WE KNOW WHY WE CANNOT ALLOW
INSTITUTION TO INVESTIGATE
ITSELF.
IT'S VERY RARE THAT IF YOU
INVESTIGATE YOURSELF YOU'LL FIND
YOURSELF GUILTY OF ANYTHING.
WE KNOW HERE THAT YOU WOULD
SEIZE INTERNAL INVESTIGATION IS
LEAD TO NOTHING.
IT'S YIELDED NO RESULTS
WHATSOEVER IN FACT THEY TOLD A
FEDERAL JUDGE LAST WEEK THAT
THEY DON'T EVEN PLAN TO MAKE IT
PUBLIC.
AN INVESTIGATION IS NEVER MADE
PUBLIC IS PRACTICALLY USELESS.
BOTH OF THESE INSTITUTIONS WERE
CHARGED WITH CARING FOR THEIR
WOMAN STUDENTS FEMALE STUDENTS.
AND THEY'VE DONE THE OPPOSITE
THEY IGNORED REPEATED COMPLAINTS
OVER DECADES.
THEY TOLD NO.
ONE ON THE U. S. C. THEY
ACTUALLY HARBOR DR TYNDALL AND
THEY PROTECTED HIM.
THE EMPOWER HIM THEY COVER FOR
HIM.
AND THEY CONTINUE TO COVER UP
FOR HIM.
AT THIS TIME RIGHT NOW WE CANNOT
TRUST THE MEDICAL PROFESSION OR
THESE INSTITUTIONS TO POLICE
THEMSELVES EVEN WHEN THEY'RE
CAUGHT THEY JUST WON'T DO IT.
SB FOUR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
WILL REQUIRE INVESTIGATIONS TO
COMMENCE IMMEDIATELY IF  DOCTOR
SUSPECTED OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
NAP WILL PROTECT PATIENTS FROM
FURTHER HARM.
AND THAT'S WHEN THE FAVOR OF IT.
I WILL SAY THIS -- THE FIRST
COMPLAINT I'M AWARE OF IT WAS
WRITTEN AGAINST USC HAPPENED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND THAT'S
THE YEAR BEFORE I SAW HIM.
IN OF A LAW LIKE THIS WAS IN
PLACE I MIGHT NEVER HAVE SEEN
HIM.
AND THEN THE WOMAN WHO CAME
AFTER ME FOR THE NEXT TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS MIGHT NEVER HAVE
BEEN VICTIMIZED BY HIM.
THIS IS IT THIS MAKES SENSE THIS
BILL MAKES SENSE TO ME.
IN MICHIGAN STATE THEY WERE SO
BAD AT INVESTIGATING THEMSELVES
THAT A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAD TO
BE APPOINTED. TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT AND IT WASN'T UNTIL
A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR WAS
APPOINTED THAT THERE WAS ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY THERE.
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO BE CONSIDERING.
FOR CALIFORNIA AND FOR USC
WEATHER HAS BEEN NO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THESE EXAMPLES PROVE WHY
CALIFORNIA NEEDS SB FOUR TWENTY
FIVE WITHOUT THIS LAW.
SEXUAL ABUSE BUT MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WILL CONTINUE IN
SECRET NO ONE WILL BE HELD TO
ACCOUNT.
AND VULNERABLE PATIENTS WILL BE
HARMED.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
TODAY THAT THANK YOU MISS NAV
SINGER THANK YOU FOR COMING
FORWARD TO TELL YOUR STORY IT
DOES LACK COURAGE TO DO THAT WE
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
AT CENTER HILL YOUR TIME HAS
EXPIRED FOR ALL YUR WITNESSES
ALL LIKE TO HAVE YOUR NEXT
WITNESS AND DO SOME CELLS AND
THEY CAN JUST SUM UP THEIR THEIR
TESTIMONY THAT WOULD BE TERRIFIC
HAVING TO AT A CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MIKE MATIC CONSUMER
WATCHDOG -- ALLEGATIONS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AS THE SHOULD NOT
BE COLLECTING DUST IN SOME
FILING CABINETS SOMEWHERE.
LIKE TO COMMAND -- SENATOR HILL
AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE FOR PROTECTING AND
SEEKING JUSTICE FOR VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT OVER OVER THE
YEARS -- AND TO BRIEF IT UP AS
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORTING COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND DO A NEED.
TO BE APPRECIATED I'M JENNIFER
SO MOST OF THE MEDICAL FOR
CALIFORNIA THE BOARD ACTUALLY A
SUPPORTIVE OF THREE OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL BECAUSE
THEY'RE APPROVED IS LET'S
PROPOSALS.
SO WE SUPPORT THE PROVISION OF
STRIKES OR COMPREHENSIVE IN
FRONT OF SUMMARY.
AND THE PROVISION THAT REQUIRES
PROBATIONARY LICENSE INFORMATION
TO STAY ON THE BOARD'S WEBSITE
AFTER APPROPRIATIONS COMPLETED
FOR TEN YEARS.
AND THE BOARD SUPPORTS A PER
VISIT PROVISION REGARDING
PHYSICIAN INTERVIEWS TO
INCLUDING THE DEFINITION OF
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT THE
FAILURE OF A LICENSEE AND
ABSENCE OF GOOD CAUSE TO ATTEND
AND PARTICIPATE IN AN INTERVIEW
BY THE BOARD.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THE FAILURE
TO BE REPEATED THE WORLD BE
TAKING REVIEWING THIS BILL IN
TAKING A POSITION ON THE OTHER
PROVISIONS AS NEXT BOARD MEETING
ON MAY THANK YOU MA'AM BEFORE
YOU GO CAN YOU GIVE ME YOUR NAME
AGAIN.
JENNIFER SOMOS OKAY BECAUSE I
HAD SOME FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
JENNIFER IF YOU COULD HANG
AROUND RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MAP BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
THE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU MATT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
CAN START [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME AND WHO WILL BEGIN.
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MEGAN ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
I REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AS THE BILL PUTS IN
PLACE THE REPORTING PROCESS THAT
WILL CAUSE EXTREME BACKLOG TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD.
NEGATIVELY IMPACT ACCESS TO CARE
AND REYES IS EXTREME CHALLENGES
IN ITS IMPLEMENTATION ALL WHILE
IGNORING THE CURRENT EFFECTIVE
AND CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PEER
REVIEW PROCESS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF EGREGIOUS MISCONDUCT AT
USC WHERE THEIR CLINIC MANAGED
TO FALL OUTSIDE OF THE REALM OF
PEER REVIEW.
INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THIS
PROBLEM DIRECTLY HOWEVER THE
BILL CAST AN OVERLY BROAD NET
FOR REPORTING WHICH WILL LEVY
HEFTY FINES ON PHYSICIANS
MEDICAL STAFF AND ADMINISTRATORS
FOR FAILING TO REPORT EVERY
MENTION.
RUMOR OR UNSUBSTANTIATED
ALLEGATION OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
WHICH REMAINS UNDEFINED UNDER
THE BILL.
THE MAY BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO NARROW
THE BILL TO ENSURE THE CLINICS
LIKE THAT U. S. C. R. WRAPPED IN
THE CURRENT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BUT IN ITS CURRENT
WRITTEN FORM WE MUST REGRETFULLY
OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS ALEX OFTEN
WITH A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION -- WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR.
ON THOSE AMENDMENTS TO DISTINCT --
AREAS OF CONCERN ONE IS THE WAY
IN WHICH THE BILL INTERACTS WITH
CURRENT LAW -- FOR EMPLOYMENT
SITUATIONS FOR LARGE EMPLOYERS
THERE'S A CONSIDERABLE
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF LAW
ALREADY ON EMPLOYMENT SO WE
WANNA KINDA WORK THROUGHOUT HOW
THIS INTERACTS WITH THOSE LAWS.
THE SECOND PART WHICH IS MORE
TRICKY IN IN WHICH WE AGREE
THERE IS A PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO
BE SOLVED.
IS -- HOW EMPLOYMENT LAW
INTERACTS WITH THE PEER REVIEW
PROCESS WE DON'T EMPLOYEE
PHYSICIANS THAT CREATES SOME
SOME COMPLICATIONS HERE -- SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION AND THIS COMMITTEE
THE MEMBER -- HAVE THE
COMMITMENT OF THE HOSPITALS TO
PROTECT OUR PATIENTS A MAN ARMED
POLICE THE FULLEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE.
GREAT I ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO MADDEN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY IN THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF PLASTIC SURGEONS IN
OPPOSITION THANK THANK THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARTS THING I WANT TO BRING THE
ISSUE BACK -- TO THE COMMITTEE --
I HAD SOME FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD IF I COULD.
SO WE JUST HEARD TESTIMONY THAT
SAID THAT -- RUMORS INNUENDO BUT
SOMEHOW TRIGGER -- THIS
OBLIGATION CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT.
ANDTHE MEDICAL BOARD DOESN'T
HAVE A POSITION THE BOARD GETS
OVER TEN THOUSAND COMPLAINTS A
YEAR AND SO ANYONE CAN CALL MAKE
A COMPLAINT TO THE MEDICAL BOARD.
THIS WOULD BE ANOTHER WAY THAT
WE WOULD GET BASICALLY WE WOULD
CONSIDER THE INFORMATION A
COMPLAINT SO.
RIGHT NOW ANYONE CAN CALL IN
WITH ANY INFORMATION THEY DON'T
HAVE NOPE THEY GIVE US WHAT THEY
HAD TO BACK IT UP BUT IT COULD
ANYONE CAN CALL IN RIGHT NOW SO
THIS WOULD BE THE SAME WAY.
IF A PATIENT FELT LIKE THEY HAD
SOME SEXUAL MISCONDUCT OR SEXUAL
ABUSE THEY WOULD TELL THAT
PERSON IT WOULD JUST.
BASICALLY BE A WHITE A
COMMUNICATION FROM THAT PERSON
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD SO CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THE PROCESS YOU GO
THROUGH TO MAKE SURE THAT RUMOR
AND INNUENDO WOULD NOT BE THE
BASIS IN WHICH USED.
HE DOES TAKE ACTION AGAINST THE
POSITION SURE SO GO THROUGH OUR
NORMAL FOR SOME PROCESS THIS IS
JUST ANOTHER TOOL FOR US TO GET
INFORMATION.
THE ONCE THE INFORMATION CAME
AND IT WILL GO THROUGH OUR
CENTRAL COMPLAINT UNIT WOULD BE
REVIEWED WE WOULD.
GET ALL THE INFORMATION
NECESSARY FOR AN EXPERT TO
REVIEW THAT INFORMATION.
IF THE EXPERT A PART IN THAT
YEAH THIS LOOKS LIKE YOU KNOW
SOME SERIOUS -- SEXUAL ABUSE OR
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT TOP AND THEN
IT WILL BE FORWARDED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO THEIR INVESTIGATIVE THE
HEALTH QUALITY INVESTIGATION
UNIT THOSE INVESTIGATORS WOULD.
YOU KNOW INTERVIEW THE PHYSICIAN
INTERVIEW ANY WITNESSES -- TO UP
TO ALL THE THINGS THEY NEED TO
GET ALL THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO MEET OUR BURDEN OF PROOF
WHICH IS VERY HIGH IT'S RIGHT
UNDERNEATH THE CRIMINAL AND
CRIMINAL LAW.
AND SO WENT SO THEY THEY'VE GOT
THAT INVESTIGATION TOGETHER THEN
IT GOES TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
DIDN'T COLLECT ALL THE
INFORMATION AND DECIDE THAT THEY
HAVE ENOUGH TO FILE AN
ACCUSATION THAT'S CALLED THE
CHARGING DOCUMENT BASICALLY --
WHERE IT SAYS THAT WE'REGOING
TO GO FOR WITH DISCIPLINE SO
THERE IS A IT'S THE SAME PROCESS
THAT ALL OF OUR COMPLAINTS IT'S
BASICALLY JUST ANOTHER WAY FOR
US TO GET INFORMATION?
THERE'S A AN ASSERTION THAT --
THIS LEGISLATION IF IT WERE TO
BE ENACTED WOULD IGNORE THE PEER
REVIEW PROCESS.
SO WE CURRENTLY HAVE A PEER
REVIEW PROCESS AND IN MANY CASES
MAYBE IN MOST CASES.
AND THIS BILL TRIES TO GET AT
THE EXCEPTIONS TO THAT WORKS NOT
OCCURRING BUT CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THE ISSUE OF OF HOW YOU'RE A
INVESTIGATION CURRENTLY DOES IT
IGNORE THE PEER REVIEW PROCESS.
NO SO THE PEER REVIEW PROCESS IS
AGAIN AS ANOTHER WAY FOR US THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO GET INFORMATION.
THE PEER REVIEW PROCESS ACTUALLY
REQUIRES IT TO GO THROUGH THE
PEER REVIEW BODY TO DO THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATION MAKE EM THEIR OWN
FINANCE IF THEY TAKE ONE OF THE
OPTIONS THAT SPECIFIED AHMAD DID
THERE IS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THE MEDICAL BOARD.
REVIEW PROCESS WILL CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN AS THOSE -- WITH ALL
THESE OTHER PROCESSES BUT REALLY
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE JUST
ANOTHER WAY FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO GET INFORMATION TO
START THAT ENFORCEMENT PROCESS.
THANK THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION -- IN THE ANALYSIS
IT RAISES A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
I WANTED TO SEE IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS.
A ONE OF THEM IS THE ABILITY OF
FIVE FIVE EMPLOYERS.
LICENSEES TO KNOW ABOUT THESE
OBLIGATIONS.
YOU SPEAK TO WHAT YOU DO TO BE
ENSURE THAT -- FOLKS -- THAT
HAVE THIS RESPONSIBILITY IF THIS
BILL WERE TO BECOME LAW HOW CAN
WE BE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
KNOWLEDGE. TO TO ENFORCE IT
CORRECTLY RIGHT SO UNLIKELY
DOING ANY OTHER BILLS PASSED WE
TRY TO GET INFORMATION OUT TO
OUR LICENSEES WHICH I KNOW IS
NOT THE TARGET AUDIENCE BUT
SOMETIMES WE WORK WITH OTHER
ASSOCIATIONS TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT LIKE WE WOULD
WORK WITH THEM.
YOU KNOW POSSIBLY THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION OR A
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE THOSE FACILITIES TO GET
INFORMATION OUT WE'VE WORKED IN
THE PAST WITH CD PH ON ALL
FACILITY LETTERS TO GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT TO FACILITIES SO
WE WOULD USE THOSE RESOURCES TO
GET INFORMATION ON THE BEST WAY.
WE COULD POSSIBLY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION.
THERE'S THAT SO THE BILL DOES
ASSESS -- PROPOSES TO ASSESS
SOME FINES.
OF SOME SIGNIFICANCE TO YOU AS
IT IS YOUR BOARD HAVE OPINIONS
ABOUT THE LEVEL OF FINES THAT
ARE PROPOSED I BELIEVE THAT THE
LEVEL FINES ARE -- EXACTLY TAKEN
FROM THE LAW AND EIGHT OH FIVE
SECTION THEM.
IT'S THE SAME AS THE FINES
IMPOSED FOR EIGHT OH FIVE
FAILURE TO REPORT AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY THOSE FINES WERE
CHOSEN FROM MY UNDERSTANDING.
SO YOU DON'T FIND THOSE FINES TO
BE EXCESSIVE UNDER HOW IT
HANDLED THESE MATTERS AND THEY
ARE IN LINE WITH OTHER FINDS AN
EXISTING LAW.
SO THERE IS ANOTHER PROVISION --
IN THE BILL THAT'S RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS OF THE EXTENDING THE
TIME IT TAKES -- FOR THE THE I
SO HEARINGS TAKE PLACE FROM
THIRTY DAYS TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT FOR THAT
FROM YOUR POINT OF VIEW.
I THINK CENTER HAS A SECULAR
JUST REMOVE I REMOVE SECTION FOR
WHICH INCLUDED THE TIME. FOR THE
I SO TWO TWO AND FOR THAT PERIOD
OF TIME FOR THAT NO LONGER PART
OF THE BILL IF IF THAT'S EXACTLY
YEAH.
THAT'S FINE OKAY VERY GOOD ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO ANSWER SOME OF MY
QUESTIONS MY COLLEAGUES MAY HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
I MEAN LOOK AROUND SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU AND I WANT THANK THE
WITNESSES WHO CAME TO TESTIFY --
ACTUALLY -- REPRESSION FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD IT IS REQUIRED BY
LAW I UNDERSTAND AS A LICENSED
PHYSICIAN THAT WE HAVE TO POST
THE MEDICAL BOARD AND THE
COMPLAINT NUMBER IN OUR
PRACTICES ARE SOME VERSION THEIR
OF PRACTICE NOTICE TO CONSUMERS
A COMPOSER GIVE IT TO THAT
PATIENT OKAY SO PATIENTS THAT.
ACCESS TO INFORMATION -- SIR
HELLO I YEAH I APPRECIATE WHAT --
SO CAN BECAUSE THERE'S A PENALTY
SIGNIFICANT PENALTY FOR FAILURE
TO REPORT -- WHAT?
CONSTITUTES AN ALLEGATION THAT'S
REPORTABLE EDWARDS.
IS IT THAT DOES IT IT DOESN'T
HAVE.
TO DESERT I MEAN CERTAINLY IF
YOU RECEIVE THE FORM I A A
LETTER SAYING THERE'S OR A IT'S
IT'S IT'S OF I'VE BEEN JUST
TRYING TO GET AT THE THAT'S WHAT
TRIGGERS THE PENALTY -- SOMEONE
SAID SOMETHING OFFHAND REMARK
AND SAYS WELL I DID MAKE A
REMARK THAT CAN TRIGGER PENALTY
AND I JUST FUNDS AND GET IDEA
ABOUT.
THE DEFINITION OF WHAT AN
ALLEGATION IS THAT WOULD THEN
TRIGGER THE PENALTY IF IT IF YOU
FEEL THE REPORT AND AND AND AND
FOR AND UNDER THE SPELL.
YEAH AND IN TO ME THE THE
CONCERN OR THE THE DEFINITION OF
AN ALLEGATION OR COMPLAINT IS.
IS ONE THAT CERTAINLY NOT IN
TERMS OF MEDICAL MALPRACTICE OR
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT THIS IS
JUST PACIFIC WE HAVE SOMEONE.
MAKES A COMPLAINT FILED THE
COMPLAINT OKAY SO SO SOMEONE
THAT IT IS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN.
A VICTIM OF SOME SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT SO SO THERE IS SOME I
I MEAN I JUST WANNA BE CLEAR
ABOUT THERE'S SOME FORMALITY TO
THE COMPLAINT AND THOUGH IT'S
IT'S NOT JUST A REMARK YOU'D
ACTUALLY SEND THE LETTER OR
REGISTER SOMETHING WITH THE
ORGANIZATION MIND THAT IN OKAY
AND THAT'S THE INTENDED.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE FILE A
COMPLAINT OR MAKE A FORMAL OKAY
TO THE EMPLOYER OR THE OKAY NICK
OR THE HOSPITAL OKAY AND I
ASSUME YOU'D BE WILLING TO WORK
ON LANGUAGE ACTUALLY REVISE THAT.
THEN THAT WAY THE ORGANIZATION
DOES THIS IS OKAY I GOT WE DON'T
WANT NOW I NEED TO SEND THIS YOU
KNOW.
FOR CONTACT THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND NOTIFY THEM OKAY SO BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THERE'S A THE
CHALLENGE ABOUT THAT DEFINITION
SO.
HAPPY TO DO THAT THANK YOU AND
IN ALSO WHEN WORKING WITH THE
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT -- THERE'S A EASE
IN REPORTING AND AND THAT THOSE --
THIS CLARIFICATION THERE AND
ALSO HAPPY TO WORK WITH THIS SEE
IN MAY AND THE ISSUES THAT THEY
RAISED.
AND I GUESS QUICK QUESTION FOR
SAM A I MEAN CENTER HILLS
REMOVED -- SECTION THE BILL THAT
I THINK WAS PROBLEMATIC IN TERMS
OF BASICALLY SENDING --
PHYSICIAN'S LICENSE BEFORE THEY
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY -- TO TO TO
ANSWERED THE CHALLENGES IS -- TO
WHAT DEGREE DOES THAT RESOLVE
SOME OF THE ISSUES YOU HAVE.
SO THAT PROVISION WAS OF A MAJOR
AB PROBLEMATIC PROVISION FOR US
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OTHER BEING WILLING TO REMOVE
THAT PROVISION.
AS IT -- WAS EVEN MORE BROUGHT I
THINK THAN EVEN MIGHT HAVE BEEN
INTENTIONALLY.
PUT INTO THE BILL.
SO THAT DOES TAKE AWAY A MAJOR
PIECE OF CONCERN AND I THINK. TO
YOUR POINT AT SOMETHING ABOUT
FILING A FORMAL COMPLAINT TO THE
ORGANIZATION REALLY DOES -- IT
HELPS GET TO NARROWING I THINK A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF WHAT WE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHICH IS ANY.
KIND OF IF YOU'RE IN THE BREAK
ROOM IN A POSITION OVER HEAR
SOMEONE SAY I HEARD SO AND SO
GOT A COMPLAINT AGAINST THEM.
THE WAY THE BILL IS WRITTEN AYE
WE READ IT TO BELIEVE THAT THAT
WOULD BE PUT SOMEBODY ON THE ON
NOTICE THAT THEY HAD TO THEN
FILED A REPORT WITHIN FIFTEEN
DAYS.
OR THEY'D BE SUBJECT TO
PENALTIES.
SO I THINK -- THAT TAKES A BIG
STEP IN IN.
NARROWING THIS IS SO THAT THERE
IS SOMETHING THAT A STANDARD BY
WHICH THE PHYSICIANS AND THE
OTHER MEDICAL STAFF KNOW WHEN
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT SO I
THINK THAT THOSE DO TAKE
EXCEPTION OUR DIRECTION.
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT STEPS.
I HAD TO GET BACK TO THE LIMIT
ON THAT OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL LET
ME SAY THANK YOU CENTER HELL FOR
FOR TAKING THOSE STEPS I THINK
THOSE IMPORTANT STEPS BUT I
CERTAINLY SHARE YOUR GOAL THAT.
AND WE NEED TO BE SURE THOSE
THAT INFORMATION GETS -- TO THE
PROCUREMENT OF AWARDS SO FORTH
AND SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT OF CENTER HELMET GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE BUT I
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU YOU AND
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND OTHERS --
ON OUR COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING.
TO MAKE THIS BILL AS GOOD AS IT
CAN BE AND I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'RE TAKING
TODAY.
TO TAKE CARE OF SOME OF THE
ISSUES AND I APPRECIATE
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUING TO WORK.
WITH SOME OF THE CURRENT
OPPONENTS TO TRY TO NARROW SOME
OF THE DIFFERENCES AS THE BILL
WAS FOR NO I AM HAPPY TO THAT
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU TO THAT
FOR THAT IN.
I THANK YOU FOR THE THE ACTUAL
AND ANALYSIS -- AND THE THE
DEFINITIONS THAT WERE IN HERE
AND AND THE THE COMMENTS I
THOUGHT IT WAS -- SUBURBAN YOU
DO HAVE AN OUTSTANDING STAFF IF
YOU KNOW.
OF THE I EAT YOU KNOW JUST AS
THE LEGISLATURE FOUND THAT PEER
REVIEW -- WAS A FAILURE IN IN
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS AND
PROTECTING OUR VICTIMS FROM
ABUSE IN THIS BUILDING -- AND
GOING BACK TO THE THE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT STUDY THAT
WAS MENTIONED IN THIS EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS -- IT CERTAINLY DOES
NOT SHOW THE EFFECTIVE PEER
REVIEW PROCESS THAT THE
OPPOSITION WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT A
CALIFORNIA STUDY ON PEER REVIEW
FOUND VARIATION.
INCONSISTENCY AN ENTITY PEER
REVIEW POLICIES AND STANDARDS
INCLUDING ON THE DEFINITION
PROCEDURES COMMENCEMENT PRACTICE
AND SUBJECT OF PEER REVIEW.
THERE'S NO CONSISTENCY NO
OPERATION THAT WOULD WORK WELL
AND ALSO MADE THE THE COMMENT
THAT -- THIS STUDY ALSO
IDENTIFIED POOR TRACKING OF PEER
REVIEW OF EVENTS OF SO I THINK
THAT -- THIS IS TIMELY IT'S
IMPORTANT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I'VE WHICH MEMBERS THE HIGH
THANK YOU SENATOR HILL AND
BEFORE WE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
BILL I WANT TO AGAIN THANK YOU
WITNESSES FOR COMING FORWARD TO
TELL THEIR PERSONAL STORIES I
THINK ALL OF US -- SAID AT A
MORE THAN A TWO YEAR TO HEAR
THAT -- FUTURE VICTIMS COULD
HAVE BEEN PROTECTED IF -- THAT
THE SYSTEM HAD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A CHAIR AND I I'D ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY KNOW
HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT THEY
TRAVEL LONG DISTANCE TO BE HERE
TODAY AND TO TO PARTICIPATE IN
FOR THEIR OF THE LOSSES OF THANK
YOU.
FOR YOUR FOR HIGHLIGHTED
HIGHLIGHTING THAT.
AND WITH THAT SENATOR LEYVA HAS
MOVED THE BILL.
THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD AYE DODD AYE
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN.
AND I WILL.
RIGHT THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
ROLES. ONE LAST TIME BEFORE
FLOOR SESSION YEARS YOU WE CAN
CLOSE THE ROLE AND ALL THE BILLS.
THAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY THANK YOU
FOR LL THE AUTHORS AND THE
WITNESSES WHO HAVE COME OUT --
TO ENLIGHTEN US WITH THEIR
TESTIMONIES SO.
WITH THAT -- WE ASK OF MY ABSENT
MEMBERS TO COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE SO WE CAN TRY TO
COMPLETE OUR WORK.
AND LET'S START WITH THE ITEM
ONE SP ONE FIFTY NINE BY WIENER.
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL
MISSION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
TO SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO CHAIR READING I LATE
JAN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
AND SO AT HAND [inaudible]
HE CALLED.
OKAY OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT.
SIX ZERO I WILL GO TO ITEM TWO
SP ONE NINETY THREE BY.
NIELSEN SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BUT SEVEN TWO ZERO CHIANG.
CHANG AYE ARE TO LET THEM
ARCHULETA I ARE THAT BILL IS OUT.
NINE ZERO GRADUATION CENTER
NIELSEN GOOD ITEM FOR SB THREE
EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR JONES.
QUESTION IS THE PAST AS A MINUTE
TO SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTES EIGHT
TWO ZERO CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D THAT BILLS AT NINE
ZERO RESOLUTION SENATOR
CHALLENGE WILL GO ON TO SB FOUR
TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR HILL.
ITEM FIVE MISSION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CURRENT THAT'S EIGHT TWO ZERO
WILK.
WILL GUIDE.
I THAT DILUTES OUT.
NINETY ZERO I'LL GO TO ITEM SIX
SB FOUR EIGHTY THREE BY PAN.
MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CURRENT BOTH EIGHT TWO
ZERO GALGIANI.
GALGIANI I'M THAT BILLS AT NINE
ZERO TAKES US TO ITEM NINE SB.
FIVE NINETY FIVE OKAY OUR MOTION
IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERR
BUT SEVEN ZERO CHIANG
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
OUR JULY.
I THE BILL IS AT EIGHT ZERO AND
WITHIN THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
THAT -- STUNT.
WE'RE GOOD.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU STAFF FOR
THE WONDERFUL HELP ON THE
HEARING TODAY AND WITH THAT WERE
GERMAN